[Music]
I'm the one
okay so my iPad is in our what number
podcast is this by the way Rob tell me
270 is that accurate five correct wow by
the way just so you know we're making up
for all the time that we've been super
on time we're starting to you know start
the podcast even sooner than we
typically do again 8 58 today the usual
time we start we got a lot of topics to
go through I think we're gonna have a
guy that's gonna join us here in a
minute uh he's uh he's fresh and he's
fit yesterday I was going to go to a
different podcast in Palm Beach called
the old and out of shape but then I
decided to go to Miami on this podcast
called Fresh and fit he'll be here uh in
a few minutes they're coming up on the
Miami traffic Miami Heat yeah can you
talk about that for a second come on
baby we'll talk about that at the end
for all our sports fans that love it
when we talk about it we don't want to
lose all our viewers right let me tell
you what we got here's what we got we
got a lot of things to talk about here
with uh the debt ceiling that was just
uh they're going back and forth with
negotiations there's six things uh six
must know Provisions we'll talk about
that the Santa's going after Trump like
never before Paul shows Dead Heat in
Florida between the census and Trump
Lindsey Graham says Russians dying is
the best money the U.S spent and right
afterwards Russia issues Lindsey Graham
arrest warrant after Ukraine comments
there's a poll that just came out that
even Jake Tapper couldn't control
himself I don't know if you saw this Rob
on the Jake Tapper poll when it was
announced 66 percent of Voters say Biden
is too old to serve four more years and
this was on CNN when he had to read this
and Jake said this is horrible there's
nothing good about this he couldn't even
hold himself
uh China blows up a U.S Navy uh largest
warship and menacing simulation it's
about to say stimulation but it's
simulation that they did same thing uh
days after Twitter blog Turkish uh
president erdogan political opponents
from uh posting on the site the
increasingly authoritarian leader won
re-election after a contested vote which
is devastating to people in Turkey Elon
Musk neuralink wins FDA approval for
human study of brain implants Mark
Cuban's talking [__] about Elon Musk
we'll get into that job market more High
School Grant forego College in the hot
labor market and America's biggest
source of jobs is cool enough we'll
discuss that Consumer Debt is officially
17 trillion for the first time streaming
services are removing tons of movies and
shows it's not personal strictly
business they say and it's more
expensive to live and workers are
tapping into their 401ks for help that
is a New York time story you know when's
the last time but uh Bud Light uh
actually sent a tweet out how long a
month since they tweeted anything and
somebody I Target uh there was a bomb
threat sent by an angry Pro Pride left
Winger so a lot of people are seeing
what's going on there with that and then
obviously you got a story you want to
talk about the Army veteran tick tock
goes biography details frustrating
experience with the V8 so Tom let's
start off with the economy here
um because a person said once before
it's the economy still stupid so we're
going to start off with the economy
more High School grant for gold College
in the hot uh labor market this is a
Wall Street Journal story that we have
here uh page 11 if you guys want to go
to it so the college enrollment rate at
the recent U.S school high school
graduate has declined to 62 percent in
2022 from 66.2 percent in 2019 that's
just three years ago as more young
people opt for Blue Collar jobs in a
strong labor market job growth in
Industries like Leisure and Hospitality
construction manufacturing and
warehousing which don't require college
degrees has outpaced overall job gains
the low unemployment rate for teenage
workers reaching a 70-year low of 9.2
percent last month has led to
significant pay increases hourly
earnings for leisure and Hospitality
workers Rose by nearly 30 percent from
April 2019 to April 2023 three wages are
also higher in Industries with
additional training requirements like
apprenticeship factors contributing to
the declining College enrollments
include the high cost of Education
College closures and uncertain return on
investment that's a big one right there
Tom uncertain return on investment and
this is Wall Street Journal saying this
that may be the biggest one out of all
of them in a lack of confidence in the
value of a decree many Americans
question the worth of a college degree
further discouraged by improving job
prospects in Blue Collar Fields Tom
wow this is a lot
um but this is basically this is one of
those stories where you read it you step
back from it and you go well actually
that makes sense and sort of you saw it
coming but you weren't paying attention
so what's happening right now is um
there's something that was left out on
that summary there you didn't leave it
out padded it wasn't in the
um wasn't in the in the story and that
is that there is a
fair to say is about 35 percent people
in this country are conservative and
very concerned about the woke things and
you have a lot of parents that are out
there that are going to orientations at
colleges saying what the hell am I doing
here sending my kid to be indoctrinated
in a woke institution so there is also
parents stepping back and saying wow is
is the college Roi worth it I'm about to
put you know 25 to 40 Grand a year in
there put 100 160 just to put my kid to
a basic school and
that's being met with hey wait a minute
you know um my uncle was a plumber and
you find out you can make a hundred and
seventy five thousand dollars a year I
looked up as a journeyman plumber not
after 20 years after like five years so
the trades are heating up the blue
collar trades are heating up giving you
know
um real Alternatives and the job market
on small business on the other side now
small businesses we're not talking about
the plumbers we're talking about small
businesses that are um 10 million
dollars in sales that's small compared
to you know large corporate and what
they're seeing is a lot of people coming
in and they still want the covid package
you know well you know there's you're
looking for a lot of bookkeepers there's
a quote from a bookkeeper that said
somebody came in they're looking for 61
bucks an hour to be a bookkeeper and
it's like 10 million dollar company you
would think wow can you afford that no
you can't
um from a perspective of what you're
talking about here I think it's
important if you're comfortable talking
about this you made a very big point
about the fact that parents are worried
about sending their kids to a woke
School the other day uh my sister and I
were talking to my niece who is wanting
to be a lawyer and she's going to a
school and we're having these
conversations about you know the school
you're going to you're going to spend a
week there there's going to be woke
experiences there that you have to just
kind of be prepared for you just took
your daughter one of them your oldest to
go to different universities if you're
comfortable giving names do it I won't
do it what was the experience like and
how immediately did you see signs of
these guys doing the woke thing in
University some of the biggest
universities in America because your
daughter has a 4.6 GPA so she's only
going to the best of universities yeah
well so we did the standard thing uh we
went on tours and you register online
and you can go to on a certain day and
they take you on a tour the first part
of the tours is you go into a large room
and there'll be somebody from admissions
talking and then there's usually like a
senior who's there to talk about the
school the experience of the school and
to personally say hey I majored in this
this is what it's all about but they
also stay with a script that comes from
the school itself and the first Topic at
a at a top 15 school that is located in
the heart of what you might call Music
City and I think we know who we're
talking about here the colors are black
and gold
um they um they basically said Anne
welcome
you are here for a tour we're so proud
of what we've done here there's a lot of
things going on here and one of the
first things we want to let you know is
how in we're not just inclusive we're
inclusive and also providing Services
you can get gender reassignment surgery
and support here at not our health
center but the hospital that's part of
the research to answer this question let
me ask you how many minutes before the
orientation started that message was
given that was within the first five
minutes tell me you're joking Tom no I'm
not I'm no I'm not and I had a parent in
front of me turns her turns around and
looks at me and and she makes eye
content and under her breath you could
hear her say she didn't curse she was
like starting with this you know and
then when we so about 20 minutes this
was a script this person was going off a
script and then said my name is so and
so yeah and this is yeah yeah exactly
but he he identified as pronouns too he
said I go by you know I go by you know
the AI that was a Shakespearean pronouns
because they're in college
so I saw a lot of people that were there
and then and then we we went on a tour
and there was a father that was there
who said something very very telling he
says I understand everybody's going to
be here just tell me about the
university and why this is the place for
my kids going to get a fantastic
education so he was not like going off
right wing and going off on somebody but
you so you have that going on as well as
the inflation intuition and college
closures and the on-campus off-campus
controversy we had during covid wait I
get the same diploma and I'm not on
campus and I don't have the labs but I
have to pay the same tuition remember
that story in milikovid that parents
were asking why am I still paying lab
fees and all these other fees to school
if it's basically the remote education
now because you're saying kids are off
campus so now I'm getting like a remote
degree like Grand Canyon University I
can you know go online and get one of
those online and so what's happening is
the high school grads are seeing all
this put all this in a pot of chili and
then say you know your your uncle was a
plumber you can make 175 a year a
plumber after five years do an
apprenticeship get your license get a
couple trucks and you can have a great
air conditioning pump the trades so
there's a lot of trade jobs are out
there and small businesses under 10
million you know they aren't going to
get you the work from home thing and so
these things are fighting with each
other and you step back from it and you
say I am so surprised
got him yeah for me this this entire
story comes down to one word and that
word is disruption
um we're we're we've seen this in cable
news to me college is the young version
of cable news we we went over the the
stats the other day where uh how many
five years ago ten years ago 70 of homes
had cable yeah in their prescriptions
and now it is now 40
um things have been disrupted whether
it's money in Bitcoin whether it's
politics and Trump and Outsiders going
against the system whether it's College
whether it's education there's no need
to go the mainstream traditional route
and if you actually look at the numbers
in college in the 1970s 1980s 60 of
college attendees were men 40 women now
it is completely flipped women make up
60 of college attendees and men make up
40 so we talk about this concept of
hypergamy and women won't date down
that's also becoming an increasingly big
problem where women are making more
money they're more educated where they
won't necessarily date down a
blue-collar guy Tom made a great Point
sometimes it can be a blue collar guy a
plumber make 150 Grand a year hell yeah
buddy make that money the problem is
would a woman date a plumber and that's
something that men need to consider when
they're going to college now for me
college comes down depends on the kind
of a plumber dummy let's just yeah
that's true
shout out to Mario Brother conferences
go ahead keep going you have different
options these days that you do that's
your sponsor read right there that's
exactly right you do have different
options these days check out my people
as a man specifically
um you can be you can get into
entrepreneurship you can get to
technical school you can get to
apprenticeship
um there's so many different options
that didn't exist
20 years ago when this whole you know
should I go to college not go to college
debate really started rearing its ugly
head and why did it rear its ugly head
let's get real here college has
increased what a thousand percent ROI in
the last 20 years has education
increased a thousand percent has
increased ten percent twenty percent as
College even taught you more the we all
know that I mean this also comes down to
indoctrination versus education we've
highlighted many times that what one in
11 professors are on the left when it
comes to college is that the number
these days
thirteen to one one out of 11 not on the
left no on the left no for every one
conservative Professor some say 11 some
say 13 but for every conservative
Professor 11 to 13 are on the left yeah
they're saying the same thing I think
yeah I think at the end of the day and I
went to college I I'm glad I went to
college I did the whole college
experience that's great I'll tell you
what if I just enter the real world 18th
probably would have made a handful of
mistakes it's sort of easy to have that
four-year window of
effing up and making F in mistakes which
is fine but at the end of the day this
is a major decision but besides getting
married and having kids what's the next
biggest decision that a young person has
to make going to college I mean if
you're going to spend a quarter million
dollars of student loan debt uh you need
to really think about that at the end of
the day this comes down to the bottom
line what's the bottom line
um what's the ROI on you going to
college now I don't want to be [__]
on College if you can get into an Ivy
League school if you can get into a
grade school if you get to a state
school if you get your college paid for
if you get free tuition if you get a
scholarship go for it but if you're just
going to some small liberal arts school
outside of state that you're paying out
of state tuition you're paying 50 Grand
a year to get some basket weaving
education it's like what's the ROI on
that house and that's something that you
really need to consider so so so so so
so far I'm gonna go to the next story so
far there's a few things that we got one
disruption which he's talking about two
is the value the same as it was before
three the woke which is scaring parents
out and four I'm gonna just start making
money right now why do I need to go to
college I can make money online creating
content doing this there's so many
different ways to make money this is all
bad signs for colleges and they're not
helping themselves as they get woker and
Walker and Walker and Pat my question
too is about what why are they all like
bowing down and like letting these the
whole woke ideology the whole Trend how
is this small minority taking over and
because think about it pat they're not
stopping companies like we've been
talking about uh dilemoving they try to
Bud Light guess what failed I am finally
convinced what's happening no it's not
the colleges man it's everybody college
no no it's not the colleges the the you
know you know how we always go back to
you know who's the they yes who's the
they who's the they yeah we got the man
in the house your seat's right here uh
uh so who's the they who's the they you
know who's the day who the who the
people are here that are the power you
want anything you're good okay so that
that's that they that's that isn't the
college no the they is colleges need
these big endowments to get the monies
so for them that are getting the big
endowments the college money themselves
they have to kind of uh abide by what
they want them to do and if you don't
you're replaceable who got you the job
so think about it who placed you in this
University to have their job that same
person that placed you in that
University Dean whatever the job is they
can take you out your loyalty isn't to
the students your loyalty isn't to the
kids loyalty has changed loyalty has
changed from CEOs of s p 500 companies
and University Deans to students and
parents to now funders and where the
money is coming from and if you don't
you don't provide loyalty to those guys
you lose your position your job your
money all of that stuff so and there's
one small not so small thing the whole
concept of student loans they've been
able to raise tuitions at astronomical
rates and not worry about the consumer
path the consumer is the student
right the consumer is the student and
the second consumer is the parents that
are paying the bill for the constitute
for the student so student loans have
been there so that they can raise
tuition and the college says just get
the student loan and who's backing those
loans the United States government I
still think though going to us going to
a school like and I know what school
that you were talking about within the
first five minutes for them to say Hey
listen we do gender reaffirming surgery
if you have a crotch we'll chop it up
what the f what are we talking about by
the way what about the school the other
day we went and we watched this new
movie by Sebastian Maniscalco and Robert
De Niro okay how was it it's freaking
funny as hell it's actually a very good
movie within the first five minutes a
gay couple's getting married okay within
the first five minutes
Tico looks at me and I took my dad he's
81 years old yeah okay and he wants to
watch the Nero movie Tico doesn't like
this kind of stuff he wants to leave so
we stay for dad two other times they had
the you know examples of what happens in
there to touch the you know ESG score to
be right so these guys are going out
there raising 50 million dollars for a
movie like this and the guys are saying
we'll give you 50 million as long as
your cast is this this this this that no
as long as your script has this we'll
approve it it's no longer who you think
they're loyal to it's changed anyways
let's move on to a different topic can I
ask one thing since you're 20 seconds
there you go there's since you're a
stats Guy this is something you should
consider somebody consider valuetainment
because we believe so heavily in stats
you've seen the stats where a high
school graduate over their lifetime will
make a million dollars yeah a college
graduate over their lifetime will make
two million dollars a master's degree ba
in everything with that will make three
million dollars so that's highlighting
the upside of college they'll kind of be
like yeah I don't about the debt stuff
don't worry about all the nonsense don't
worry about the gender reaffirming
surgery don't worry about that just
follow the money but if there were stats
out there which I'm sure we can put
together on all right if you go this
route not like an on-college route the
entrepreneur route this is how much
money you can make the Elon Musk route
if you will the Jeff Bezos route the
Mark Zuckerberg route dropping out of
college that's something that I think
should be highlighted more and not
pushed to the side I agree all right I
want to talk about the most important
story in the economy today testosterone
levels plummeting in young men due to
porn consumption as a link to social
isolation shows real problem the sun
young men's social isolation and Retreat
from society are linked to changing
norms and discomfort with redefine
masculinity however studies indicate
that plummeting testosterone levels in
young men possibly influenced by
excessive porn consumption may may also
contribute to their desire to separate
from society testosterone levels play a
crucial role Beyond sexual desire
impacting body and facial hair muscle
mass bone density fertility mood and
social anxiety excessive consumption of
pornography is associated with low
reproductive hormone levels in men which
can contribute in reduced testosterone
levels and potential social isolation uh
natural way to boost testosterone level
include improving Sleep Quality
getting sunlight exposure and taking
Vitamin D supplements consuming omega-3
fish fatty acids and engaging in
strength training exercises last night I
had a great time with these guys at
fresh and fit with migrant you guys are
freaking amazing at what you do
what do you think about this story
masturbation porn testosterone level
what do you have to say about that yeah
um it's it's a combination of things and
I was actually just writing some notes
as you were speaking about it I would
say there's a couple things that are
contributing to this one is women are
more successful now than ever before so
a lot of guys feel like they can't
compete or they can't measure up you got
you know an influx of pornography that's
huge you can get it for free anywhere
anytime on your phone at the you know
drop of a hat video games right become
more and more immersive more and more
interactive they've grown in popularity
significantly it's probably one of the
most uh popular ways of entertainment
nowadays they're beating out movies and
television then you got obesity right
being fat is fairly acceptable in the
west nowadays it's okay to be fat
um you also have guys in general that
are just lazy thanks to technology and
everything else that we have nowadays
people aren't as social guys don't feel
the need to get out there and get to
know women anymore a lot of guys are
socially awkward
um you know this is through the rise of
social media dating apps Etc there's a
lot of guys that have issues right where
they're good-looking guys and they're
able to get Garner attention from women
but they don't know how to speak or
convey themselves properly because they
don't have the adequate social skills
where they've been speaking to people
for a good amount of time and learning
you know certain social cues how to
speak properly Cadence speaking from an
active voice versus passive voice when
speaking to women because women
typically respond very favorably to the
active voice versus the passive voice so
all these little things right might seem
like small little insulated insulated
incidents but if you add them all
together as snowballs and creates kind
of what we have like what they call the
Lost bar Generation
Um so in general all of these things
plants when there's more to but those
are just some of the ones I could think
off the top from your but very
insightful by the way and and if you're
if you are not uh familiar with fresh
and fit I'm sure our audience is because
we had my run on before and these guys
are about to do a live event this Friday
from 6 to 10 pm at the 59.90 live
building if you want to find out more
about the tickets so we're going to put
the link below around 5990live.com this
Friday uh Adam Tom I'm sorry Adam
very weird dynamic it's gonna be a lot
of ladies there there's gonna be a very
different kind of messaging but you're
gonna be entertained and maybe if you
brought Tom that would change
my top no offense
because Walter is in love he's going to
be there I'm going to drag him away
Tom what are your thoughts uh uh uh you
know because your uh you and I are from
a you know different generation we got
three gen we no we got two generations
here's what we got right if we really
think about it
um
porn back in the days when you were 14.
okay that's VHS that's kind of stuff
that's kind of like hey dog what do you
got
you know what he's doing like all those
times news versus today what what what
do you know from like your your
perspective on how bad porn can be for
young boys well first of all ready uh
Myron's talking about let's talk about
ice social isolation and we have become
a socially isolated Society so I'm gonna
touch porn last but I'm going to touch
this
touch it Tom I said the word but what he
brought up was video games in the
internet itself makes us more
isolationist for entertainment and it's
and it's immersive and it's distracting
and hours of a session go by that leads
to us being very sedentary which leads a
sedentary life directly leads to like
you know obesity and health issues and
what they're pointing out not getting
out uh side for vitamin D and sunlight
exposure and there's a couple of um
great programs that were like the the
challenge like 60 day programs and part
of that program is 60 minutes outside
taking a walk around lunch brisk walk
getting sunlight so we all of this is
coming together what Myron just said is
dead on what's Happening you know uh on
porn that's even worse is it it
objectifies women and it perfects women
there's it's like you're you're
objectifying women and by what you're
looking at and then you're only looking
at like people who are in amazing shape
and so that also creates this false
fantasy and and leaves men you know not
capable to engage in regular
relationships the other part I look at
it add all of this up at everything that
we up and look at this hey Pat when you
grew up
did you know the names of your neighbors
across the street and on either side of
you
yes you did so did my mom so did my dad
today
I have to proactively go meet my
neighbors people usually don't know
their neighbors and it's because the
American society all of this porn and
everything else has made us more
isolated people if you ask someone how
many really close friends do you have do
you know that your neighbor across the
street what their situation is do you
know your neighbors on either side of
you would you trust one of them to take
care of your dog if you're out of town
we've also become I'm interested in what
Myron thinks about this more isolated as
a people and a culture and it's it's
it's negative well I'll tell you one
thing we've seen the stats out there
that men are just becoming weaker I
think testosterone levels have dropped
one percent every year since the 1980s
so in the last 40 years or so
testosterone levels have dropped 40
you've highlighted how men can't even do
as much weight lifting they used to
perform so look rather than highlight
all the negatives we can go down a
Litany of list of what's going on with
men what can you do to basically
increase your testosterone so you can do
the Nash natural stuff get the [__] out
of the house work out get some sunlight
sleep well eat well do what you have to
do there's also testosterone supplements
that you can actually take trt this type
of things we've actually had a recent
sponsor called tricesterone that
basically helps men increase their
testosterone I think at the end of the
day you have a choice to make as a man
do you want to kind of go down this
feminization of men path or do you want
to man up and become the best version of
yourself and the men you know only
probably 20 percent of men are actually
going to meet us at that point and uh
you're right yeah um oh sorry no no I
mean that's essentially the end of the
day and if you just basically want to
get feminized in this modern fem-centric
society you know there's plenty of
avenues for you for that but if you want
to listen to the right people not the
right people in your ear and have the
right coaches and leaders and mentors
around you uh it is possible to be a man
in today's society and this is something
that I kind of get hit on a lot because
you know people always say oh Myron
you're really critical of women I'm like
well you clearly don't watch the daytime
show because I'm even worse more
critical of the men and what I've said a
lot of times is we need to bring
bullying back right and I know oh my God
that's all controversial the reason why
I say that is because bullying is a very
natural way of letting you know that
you're inadequate with your peers right
and if they tell you hey you're fat or
hey you're a loser Etc a lot of the
self-improvements that I've made right
throughout my adolescence into my
adulthood came from people bullying me
and people say oh but his trauma is bad
no you need that you need to be smacked
in the face sometimes and learn you're
not good enough right now you need to
become better and the thing is now we
have a participation trophy Society
where just by showing up you're rewarded
and quite frankly that's not enough it's
not about just showing up it's about
being consistent and showing up every
day and doing it correctly but we live
in this world nowadays where people
quite frankly are soft right when I say
things like stop being I don't know I
don't want to swear right because we're
in the morning you know stop being a
[__] right they're like oh you're uh
misogynistic toxic blah blah blah no you
need men need trauma to grow they need
it right I've always said trauma builds
men but it destroy always women and the
reason for that is because by the time
you're old enough and you want to
actually date a woman Etc she's looking
for those Battle Scars she's looking for
you to have that experience she's
looking for you to have beaten that
adversity she's looking for you to have
made yourself into something the only
way you're going to be made into
something is by going through something
and you know quite frankly living a
society now where the guys are just soft
my brother for example right going back
to accomplishing that you guys were
talking about before I was at his
graduation last week I had to take a few
days off to go up to Connecticut uh and
you know Southern Connecticut State
University that's where he graduated
from and during the speech right they
were talking about being all-inclusive
and oh yeah it's about this is a happy
harmonious campus and all this other
crap and I'm like damn I graduated
college you know 2013 about 10 years ago
out of Northeastern and they were
starting to get woke back then but now
it's on a whole other level and not only
that College college campuses have
become more and more expensive right
when I went to Northeastern around 40K I
think it's probably like closer to 50 to
70k nowadays so you got
all these things working in tandem to
quite frankly make men weak right we
have this soft-ass Society where we're
not telling them that they need to
actually go out there and Achieve and
become somebody and then we also have
the video games the Obesity the
mediocrity being socially accepted oh
it's okay you're finding the way that
you are no it's [__] not okay the
only people that are accepted however
they come are women not men you must
become a somebody as a man I think
that's why our podcast becomes so
popular because we're telling guys there
is a burden of performance you have to
go out there and do something being fat
is unacceptable being stupid is
unacceptable beating me a mediocre is
unacceptable you can't be saved like a
woman can for being pretty you must get
out there and become a [__] somebody
but the problem is that we don't bully
you guys enough we don't tell them that
they're losers we don't tell them that
they're fat we don't tell them that
they're stupid we need to go back to
letting people know that they're
inadequate and then they'll go ahead and
you know it's wild that he's saying that
somebody could be listening to this and
saying what kind of a freaking message
is that I grew up bullying and this this
that but I will tell you you know over
the years uh running a sales team I
recruit a lot of young men and young
women okay and we we help them become
agents Sheena sapala who right now you
know they they do very well for them so
they make a couple million a year and
their business does around 40 million 30
million a year okay
she played Sports she played softball
she played softball for college and she
just got inducted to the Hall of Fame of
her High School in Sacramento yeah and
you know what's crazy you I can sit down
with her and give her feedback and
Challenger she takes it she has no
problem okay uh I can give feedback to
guys that are in the military they can
take it no problem
but if I notice the guys that I have the
hardest time with giving feedback guess
what they never played Sports yeah and
it's so wild I know the names obviously
I will not say it but God forbid if you
give those guys feedback they're so
heartbite there's that's not the way
that works with me that's not the way
that this works for me I want the
feedback to be this way I don't okay
totally fine but the reality of it is
that guy missed out on the opportunity
being coached under somebody that kicked
their ass get off your ass run forward
let's go like I saw Dylan was playing
for this baseball team and their coach
was like eight years old it's like what
are you guys doing get out there I want
you to try harder you guys are being
sloppy what are you guys doing on the
past year your teammates hitting here
pay attention to the game this one guy
was a former player and I'm watching
saying wow you just put him in check
like this well if you do that for three
four five years and then eventually you
know what you think it is you think
that's normal so when somebody later on
is like I'm not offended by it you
shouldn't see my coach back in the days
years ago there's there's Concepts about
being around intimidating tough
environments like this toughens you up
and if you stand up so I think you got a
very good point there it happens in
business all the time by the way well
Pat do you guys do you guys think it's
like happening intentionally like
there's a concerted effort alpha males
they're trying to get rid of them look
what happens with Tay and everybody like
people like you they don't want people
like us that are alphas out there like
it's almost like something is happening
to make us soft because like well if
let's just say aliens wanted to come
attack you know yeah you have to get rid
of the strong feral crazy attacking men
because we are getting soft as [__] bro
like America is absolutely and just
because now feelings are more important
than anything else like you said I know
what people think about the bullying but
you need a little like a push if I say
somebody's morbidly obese there's a girl
that couldn't walk through the aisle on
an airplane that's what she said
remember we talked about Adam and you
know she was like this is discrimination
against me they sure give me an extra
she's like no make the planes bigger
right like I want a big huge big ass so
it's like I feel like do you feel like
my like it's are they doing it it's is
there a power that's behind this to make
us all really really soft well yeah when
you when you emasculate the men well
then you can take over because the thing
is with men is that you know since the
beginning of time
me and Andrew have had talks about this
like since the beginning of time men are
prepared to fight to defend their belief
systems women are not right there's a
reason why they would kill off the men
and take the women and the children as
prisoners and you know they're doing
that now but they're doing it much more
intelligently right and if you look at
and this kind of goes into other things
as well if you look at you know now when
we have wars with other countries or
whatever we're not going into actual
physical confrontation with them like
World War II no what are we doing we're
doing proxy wars we're doing what we're
doing right now we're Ukraine and Russia
right we're sending in spies we're
collecting information on other
countries we're getting a classified
information
um given to us or whatever stealing
information stealing secrets so
everything is kind of done
surreptitiously now and uh destroying
the men is also being done right now
because if you destroy the strong men
who's going to question and stop you
because guys like us ask questions we
talked about this yesterday on our show
and questions are annoying for the
authorities so anytime you're able to
question or push back or Rebel that's an
issue for them I'll say one more thing
because I fully agree with the bullying
component yeah I played Sports my whole
life played college football all
basketball the whole deal there's you
know talk about locker room talk yeah
you know nothing is as vicious as a 12th
grade high school locker room oh my God
if you ain't up to par and you know if I
look back at the coaches I've had in my
life the coaches who were the the guy
that you're like [__] this guy I hate
those teams always did the best 100
because he demanded accountability and
some guys don't want that but at some
point you need to get in line last point
you talk about bullying that's
peer-to-peer yeah I also think there are
lack of male role models these days we
talk about single uh single parent
households yeah uh something that's
plaguing America the welfare state
relying on the government
um yesterday before the fresh fit
podcast I actually was taking care of my
nephew 10 year old guy we're playing uh
football
this kid is the king of excuses every
time I throw him the ball oh that the
lace hit my head dropped it all the sun
got my eye at one point I got I said
shut the f up either catch the ball or
say my bed that's it you're allowed two
words my bad or catch the ball and you
saw that's it I'm telling you and it I
mean I trained him like a coach I'm not
like I spend you know maybe a day a week
with him and we spent an hour playing
football and you know the most amazing
thing you're talking about a kid who
plays YouTube video game he's a kid he
goes this is better than any video game
or any YouTube video I loved it I go
that's right kid and I was hard as hell
on the kid I said catch the ball or just
say my bad don't say anything else to be
fair he's not he's actually not
accustomed to that style no at all at
all so that's a shocker when it happens
the first time so kudos to him yeah for
reacting the way he did and not running
crying about it yeah no I mean I do
coach him from time to time this isn't
the first time but I just was fed up
with the excuses but this this talks
about you know what do you call the the
trophy uh culture yeah the participation
trophy yeah I could have just been like
hey man I'm happy you're out here trying
to catch the ball I don't catch the
goddamn ball Randy iron sharpens iron I
have vivid memories in my childhood I
grew up with uh with Jordan Reed you
played for the 49ers and his brother
David yep exactly I remember I grew up
with them in New Britain Connecticut and
I remember as a kid getting bullied all
the time because David was a little bit
older than us Jordan was around my age
we used to play them at basketball pick
up basketball they'd always used to beat
us play football baseball play all these
Sports and we always get smoked by the
older kids but it incentivized us yeah
to wake up early go to the basketball
court practice in the morning train get
better Etc because iron sharpens aren't
like we're going to beat them they keep
talking smack and we eventually did beat
him in one pickup game and then lost but
the point is you remember that what
motivated us yeah it really motivated us
to get out there and be better and I
don't think young men have that same
stimuli that they used to have before
you don't even see kids outside playing
anymore at the basketball courts or
going outside doing anything they're
more concerned with you know subscribing
to only fans and whacking off to porn or
playing Video Games Etc we have the
fattest kids we've ever had kids aren't
outside playing sports and I think
sports are honestly nowadays if you're a
parent you need to enroll your kids in
something whether I don't care if it's
music Sports whatever it is because they
learn discipline from that they learn
how to deal with other people they learn
teamwork they understand that there's a
chain of command with a coach you learn
so many life lessons from participating
in sports that it's insurmountable
they're not going to get that those type
of life lessons anything else and you
learn how to not be a [__] I want to
tell you a story my dad in the house has
one trophy okay that he kept since I was
14 do you know the story or no no I
can't I was 14 years old he's kept us
one trophy so I'm like listen why did
you keep this trophy he says well it
reminds me of what happened that one
night in Echo Park in uh in L.A so if
you don't know Echo Park Echo Park
wasn't the safest area in the 90s it's
like it's it's a terrible Place actually
in the 90s so I'm playing in this league
it's a it's a troubled teenagers League
called the Century City basketball
association something like that okay and
one day we're playing against these
other guys four of our players don't
show up we only have five and we're
playing against guys it's uh the the
other group it's blood [__] we got
Diamond anyways we said the other guy
helicopter show up shooting it was a
pretty bad day but that game we lost by
101 players you know what I love about
that game we I've scored six points I'll
never forget exactly how many points
your highest scoring game ever it's the
highest score trust me that's a
highlight reel for me of the bank oh my
God so we lost by 101 points and there
was a small little you know the the they
give the bigger trophy for the guys that
when they give us a smaller than my dad
kept it he says is to show this game the
way you lost to keep you humble for the
rest of your life how bad you guys got
your asses whooped oh my God by these
guys it was phenomenal we laugh about it
till today but it's right you need those
types of moments to keep you humble in
life and in business if you don't if all
is coming around we need to bring that
and put it right here on the Man Trophy
that trophy is one of the most important
one more thing I want to say too about
why Sports and activities are so
important especially for guys in their
adolescent years uh women too is because
it keeps you away from doing stupid
things I can't tell you how many times I
was offered we'd growing up as a kid or
hey you want to go drink or you want to
do something stupid and I always said no
why because I had to go play basketball
or when I was in college I was a visual
athlete I was a rower
uh that kept me away from doing a lot of
stupid things I never smoked weed in my
life didn't drink like that in college
did a party like that because I knew I
had to be up at five o'clock in the
morning to train on Charles River so did
like sports creates discipline which
then forces you to not be involved in a
lot of stupid things that can get you
jammed up you know what's so crazy that
you say that so all throughout High
School I was that dude that was like I
don't drink I don't do drugs I'm that
guy like no I'm an athlete football
basketball all-county the whole deal get
to college
and all my football player teammates are
like we're going out drinking we're
partying smoke this trying this I was
like this is the antithesis of what I
was looking for guys yeah but you are
right that that college does keep you
out of credit uh keep you out of trouble
yeah how many guys they conducted into a
Hall of Fame that say thank God for my
mom for enrolling me in sports if not I
would have been gang banging out here it
kept me away from a lot of stupidity
growing up in in new brain Connecticut
which isn't the best place to grow up
right it was a 50 dropout rate in New
Britain high school and then going into
college that kept me away from like you
know partying and doing a bunch of
stupid stuff and I was just focused on
Sports and it just kept me focused Myron
I went to I went to New Bern High too
and on the
hurricanesville I was raising the rent I
was raped are you joking I swear to God
we were born in Yonkers we were syrians
we moved my father got a job in
Connecticut I'm on New Britain High
School 1996 I graduated oh we gotta talk
bro yeah why is banana all high school
when you said new brand I go who the
hell knows about hard hitting New
Britain yeah
Miguel de Jesus was shot my dad I'll
never forget Myron my father dropped us
off in front of the school uh seven
seven something in the morning as he's
driving off this guy was a Latin King
standing in front of the school he just
got back from a suspension car pulls up
shoots him dead in front of us they
drive that's the school that we went to
we had one day off and they brought us
right back into that school yeah because
New Britain people think Connecticut is
like soft but the thing is is that all
the most of the money in Connecticut is
concentrated in the South um Southwest
going towards New York City yeah but if
you go into Central Connecticut or
Northern Connecticut it's not so nice
especially think of Connecticut
but like Bridgeport and New Haven and
bro oh yeah Central Connecticut yeah
we're gonna go start a fight in the
office
let's talk let's talk let's talk economy
Consumer Debt passes 17 trillion for the
first time despite slide in mortgage
demand this is a CNBC story I'm gonna
read two stories together because they
have a lot to do with each other so 17
trillion dollars increasing by nearly
150 billion dollars the first quarter of
2023 despite a decline in mortgage
demand total and debtness Rose by 2.9
trillion dollars since pre-pandemic
levels in 2019 new mortgage orientations
including refinancing hit the lowest
level since 2014 with a significant
increase decrease of 35 compared to the
previous quarter that the client in-home
loans can be attributed to higher
interest rates which reach around 6.4
percent following multiple rate
increases by central banks the mortgage
refinance and boom fuel by lower
interest rates has come to an end CNBC
however its impact will be felt for
years years
Myron they love the way I speak English
so you know with millions of homeowners
having refinanced their mortgages during
the pandemic period despite interest
Rising interest rates mortgage
foreclosures remain low while
delinquency rates okay so now this leads
to the other one watches your 401k
it's more expensive to live and workers
are tapping into the 401k's New York
Times story uh ex Americans are
increasing time and retirement's cost of
living campaigns experts are warned that
the number of workers marking making
hardship withdrawals from their 401ks
could rise as people struggle with
insufficient short-term savings and face
unexpected expenses Tom thoughts on
these two stories well it's it's a
simple it's a simple tragedy
um we covered a story here uh one week
ago that credit card debt had just
touched one trillion dollars that's just
revolving credit card debt and it was a
bounce up from about 800 in middle of
pandemic and the stimulus checks had
actually taken that down to about 720.
so it moved almost 300 billion dollars
just credit card debt and what is
happening here is no one wants to talk
about it you can spin the economy and
say you know Joe Biden's doing a great
job look at all this checkbox checkbox
checkbox what's the reality people
inflation is killing people and they are
they've run their credit cards up to a
trillion dollars worth total Consumer
Debt now passes 17 trillion for the
first time even though mortgage demand
is down why is mortgage demand down
because mortgage right now I think it's
6.87 percent this morning if you wanted
a 30-year fixed mortgage on a half a
million dollar house and you've got
solid credit it's almost seven percent
so you're getting squeezed so what do
you turn to if you don't have a credit
card and you're getting toward the limit
what do you turn to you turn to your
401k and check this out I disagreed with
this when it happened but buried that
story from New York Times is the secure
2.0 act the secure 2.0 that you know
what it did this is your government
doing this they want they want people to
be dependent on the government they do
not want Financial Independence security
it allows people
to make a withdrawal that they call is a
security withdrawal or a financial
hardship withdrawal they're making it
easier for people in their 40s and 50s
to tap into the 401K because the
government knows what's going on they
knows what's going on with the with the
credit cards this shows you just how bad
things are right now because people say
well what did they do before what did
they do before why are they doing 401ks
now you know what people with homes used
to get a HELOC what can't you do now if
interest rates are almost seven percent
at two percentage points for a HELOC
right Pat that's a little bit more for
the second mortgage for the HELOC well
that makes a HELOC nine percent if
you've got equity and you can do it and
they can't the bank looks at it and says
I'm sorry you're kind of maxed out here
I can't I can't give you another 50
Grand on a credit line HELOC that you're
going to use for living expenses so what
this is showing is just how tough it is
on the American middle class right now
it's tougher than tough I think there's
two parts of the story there's no macro
and the micro the macro I actually don't
give a [__] I'll tell you why uh every
year we see that these numbers get
inflated and inflated I remember back in
2008 during the uh economic crisis uh
what was the bailout 800 billion there
was nothing with the word t in it
nothing with the word trillion that's
right tarp there's not meaning there was
like the first stimulus 2.4 billion so
I'm sorry 2.4 trillion the cares act and
then there was multiple stimulus checks
trillion we've seen the U.S debt go from
10 15 20 we're at what 31 trillion
dollars in inflation Rising these macro
numbers are just going to get larger and
larger and larger and larger and that's
something just we need to understand and
get comfortable with not saying I'm
happy about it not saying anyone should
be but that's the reality that we're in
today we're now working with trillions
no longer but it used to be cool to be a
millionaire millionaire who gives a [__]
about that yeah now you're a billionaire
a billionaire I know a couple
billionaires now we're talking about
Elon Musk becoming a trillionaire we're
now in trillionaire territory guys
billionaire ain't cool anymore
millionaires like broke boy at this
point and you need to understand that as
far as the micro goes
um we've seen that over since covet
something that we've all learned the
terminology the k shaped economy the
rich have gotten richer and the poor
have gotten poorer which one are you
because if you're in the middle class if
you ain't improving you're digressing so
you know I feel bad for the middle class
for sure times are not easy inflation
has been a mess Consumer Price Index has
been tough to deal with Vinnie does
videos on the price of eggs instead of
buying his girl an engagement ring he
bought her a [__] egg and she loved
her she loves it on Vinnie but it just
at the end of the day this comes down to
personal accountability personal finance
and and handling what you got to handle
as a man is there any like oh no no no
no no so Tom we hear all these facts and
I mean we're not in government so they
you know we don't really know but how
can we what what can they do to like
stop this like to slow this [__] down or
like the government or you know like is
it the presidency or like because
obviously it didn't it wasn't happening
years ago it's happening hardcore now
Pat what's the why is it going like that
so bad and people are broke as [__]
but like what could they be doing
differently you need a bad ass SOB who's
gonna say listen you you the people the
populace
you ain't gonna like what I have to say
that's what I want to hear like we need
to do some control damage to this
country right now that's what I wanted
unfortunately that is a not a winning
message well unfortunately you want to
keep piling on the debt and they've all
done it of course Bush of course Obama
Trump Biden they all can get the blame
they all can get it you need a badass
SOB who looks like the rock talks like
the rock but doesn't necessarily act
like the rock but so but and that comes
in and says we need to clean up our act
so all right so Adam let's just say
Trump comes in let's say Trump wins the
nomination he comes in he wants what is
he gonna do what would he would you
think his track record he's already put
on five trillion dollars of debt to the
economy so he wouldn't do [__] so he
wouldn't do anything I'm not saying what
he'll do his second term but I'm saying
based on his first
every time you say that give the
disclaimer that's during covet relief
when it was a [__] show and nobody had a
clue what to do so when you're
explaining that it's important to put
things into the the other day Joe Biden
put a post that no one in the history of
mankind created more jobs than him which
was [__] which is [__] so but
that's also [__] so we have to call
out the [__] in on all sides I get
what you're saying what I will say to
you from my standpoint is he's right
we've talked about this many times the
right things to campaign on today are
unfortunately not winnable okay to get
out there and give the message of here's
what we need you need to go no the other
guy's giving me free stuff you're not
why am I going to vote for you I'm not
going to vote for you like this whole
debt ceiling negotiation they're having
right now we're going to the
story next is they're negotiating about
how much money they can spend like just
think about it how much money they can
spend and one side is saying let's spend
less the other side is saying no we got
to spend more right okay the other part
also in this thing here is the fact that
as an individual the more independent
people there is
the less they want the debt ceiling to
be raised the more independent earners
there is the less they rely on somebody
to take care of them financially think
about who is voting for more entitlement
programs actually think about do you
need entitlement programs do you need
entitlement programs do I need
entitlement programs do we need
entitlement programs no who with the job
needs entitlement programs actually
think about that question who who is
taking care of their family their wives
their kids their husbands their
responsibilities who wants entitlement
programs the only people that want
entitlement programs is what the people
that are not wanting to do the leg work
not wanting to go out there and improve
not wanting to get a new skill set so as
long as there's as long as they increase
everybody's trying to increase their
subscribership the left they need to
increase the amount of people that need
entitlement programs the more people
need entitlement programs the more
relevant and the Democratic party will
be the more people increase that don't
need entitlement programs people are
going to one day wake up and say I'm
sorry step aside guys you don't need to
solve my problems I got it you don't
need to take care of my financial
responsibilities that's on me so but
that's going to take 20 years to fix and
it's going to take
that philosophy staying on point today
we're living at a time where it's like
well look how rich that goes look how
rich this is look how rich that is it's
so confusing where they want people
relying on the government and they've
done such a good job at the recruiting
so many people entitlement programs it's
very hard the moment you start giving
things away for to people for free like
this is the one thing we talked about on
the podcast I don't know if you remember
that one book a toxic uh uh what's the
name of the book toxic um charity do you
remember when we talked about toxic
Charities the toxic charity there's five
things right five phases of toxic
charity when you give you give once you
elicit appreciation you give twice you
create anticipation you give three times
you create expectation okay you give a
four time it becomes entitlement the
fifth time you establish the dependency
and I would add a sixth thing the moment
you stop giving you become an enemy so
one more time you give once you listed
appreciation hey man thank you so much
for that that was great you didn't have
to you give a second time oh okay cool
so it's kind of like you're gonna do it
again I'm anticipating you give a third
time it's expectation where is it you
give a fourth time now you're entitled
here let's go you give a fifth time you
establish dependency and you stop doing
it you're an enemy so imagine if the
political party that says hey guys
moving forward we're not going to give
anything you're the number one enemy of
the people to the entitled people I know
it's an issues too real quick uh
speaking from the the home side because
as you guys your audience may or may not
know I'm a real estate investor I have
four properties down here in Florida and
another nine up in Connecticut and yeah
I mean I remember buying houses back in
like 2020 2021 I was getting interest
rates at like the threes the fours and I
was like wow this is awesome and you
know it was a bidding war I was
competing with everyone I was competing
with investors people trying to buy a
home first time home buyers Etc now your
interest rates right for an investor or
closer to eight percent and 6.4 if you
want to buy a home if you want to buy
his own your primary residence but if
you want to buy as an investor you're
getting you know mid seventh eight
percent interest rate even with good
credit so now it's worked out good for
me because now I don't have as many
competitors but going back to what you
guys said who does this hurt mostly the
middle class because now it's not it
doesn't make sense for them to buy a
house because it's too goddamn expensive
with interest rates so I mean do I see
the interest rates coming down they're
fluctuating quite a bit or whatever and
there's ways around it maybe you can get
an adjustable rate mortgage or you could
buy points at closing which is going to
be costly but regardless it definitely
has ostrich as the middle class where
only pretty much investors are the only
ones that can buy a home now so if
you're an investor it's a great time to
get in because you don't have to compete
with as many people but yeah the
interest rates are more than doubled
that's why you see BlackRock buying up
everything right exactly they're buying
up all the single family homes can you
pull up that entitlement thing one more
time he has a write-up okay guys it's so
funny because we can that's politically
that you're talking about
um but this is the this is applicable in
any phase of life so we all know that I
used to be in The Nightlife world and I
still do that it's so funny because
there's this like I'll give one quick
anecdote a buddy of mine is a big
nightlife promoter one of the biggest in
Miami he's going back and forth on
social media arguing with a with a woman
Myron shocker alert her yeah probably
and um so I was there the night that it
happened and basically The Story Goes
Like This she had to wait in line to get
into a club one of the biggest clubs in
Miami live uh for a half hour okay the
club was packed sold out and
he lets her in free every single time
her and her girls they drink free you
know we talk about number one
appreciation hey thanks for letting me
in all my friends really appreciate you
thank you
um anticipation hey we're coming we'll
see you soon got you all good no worries
expectation hey I'm here I'm in line
where are you hey I'm coming to get you
all right cool entitlement hey we're my
free drinks uh dependency I'm in line
where are you that they're posting each
other's stories you know online and he
likes he's like at the end of the day
sorry if I curse listen [__] I don't
owe you anything yeah yeah I've been
letting you and your friends come in for
a free drink for free for years and now
you want to come in and act all entitled
to the club sorry baby girl you need to
wait I feel this and that he's like all
right well best of luck out there but
that is a real life story of
entitlements I say good for him for
standing up yes and saying no you know
go figure it out for yourself there
isn't listen think about the most
annoying people in your life okay or
when we've been annoying because we've
also been annoying at times whether you
were eight years old nine years old 13
years old we've all been part of the
Annoying camp or we've been part of the
camp where people haven't owed you think
about who is the most annoying people in
your life that drain the best energy out
of you go to those two or three people
you know exactly who those people are
right they're spoiled ones okay so let's
just say spoiled ones number one is what
spoiled who else are the most annoying
people that suck the best now it's
complaining they're never happy yes
owes them everything because I got
spoiled complainers
victims who else ungrateful ungrateful
who else
leeches leeches what would you say my oh
man I mean I don't want to sound like an
[__] this is Myron Gaines opinion
only not the rest of uh pbd podcast but
this is a lot of modern day women behave
this way and when you were mentioning
the club situation in my head I was
thinking about right right this is why I
say being a gentleman right people get
controversial take care I've always said
you know most girls don't deserve silver
chivalry anymore and women killed
chivalry and the reason why is because
it used to be women appreciated nice
guys but nowadays if you're a nice guy
is you're looked at as weak and they're
going to punish you for it so chivalry
nowadays is supposed to be earned from
women but guys make the mistake and come
in as a nice guy thinking oh yeah let me
go this route and she's gonna like me it
doesn't work that way because women are
so uh how do I say this they're the um
they don't appreciate nice genuine
gestures for men anymore you know what I
mean it's they get all detected it's
expected nowadays thanks to the internet
it simps have [__] it up for everybody
so thanks to the Internet thanks to
social media thanks to all this other
stuff it's basically made women feel as
though I am superior to the average guy
an average woman doesn't think that uh
an average guy is on her level she
thinks I deserve a guy that's at least
three four five points above myself even
though I'm only at five on the sexual
Market scale but the reason for that is
going back perfectly with the steps that
you mentioned with appreciation
anticipation and expectation and time
element dependent and then if you don't
give it to them let's say you do take a
girl on a date and she doesn't
reciprocate that attraction you say you
know what we're going to split this bill
she's going to look at you as an enemy
why because there's this preconceived
notion that you as the guy need to bow
down to her I I got in an argument
recently with a girl so hang on a second
let's go through so we got victimhood
yeah we got spoiled we got complainers
we got ungrateful we got leechers we got
modern day women we got entitled what do
we solved for right now this question of
the most annoying people that suck the
best energy out of them
naggers liberals liberals okay but but
if you say liberals a lot of liberals
will be uh a lot of these qualities
right so then you got what crap magnets
okay so crap magnets okay you know you
know what's you know what's the best uh
question here to ask with the following
here's a question which which side
produces more of these
okay those who lean on the government to
take care of them or those who are
independently taking care of their
families the left is way more clearly
so how did that happen then you know
what happens with their okay if the left
views
oh the the America's kids as their kids
because this is a village right we're
living in a village America right
whatever you want it takes a village
yeah yeah oh it's not your kids it's uh
uh our kids uh yeah it's our kids right
um uh so so hang on one second so so if
that's the case then who gets judged for
the kind of kids they raise the left us
you know what kind of people you're
raising looters
victim with mentality spoiled
complainers ungrateful leechers modern
day women crap magnet uh would you say
liberals entitled bit bitter naggers
your philosophies are producing these
types of people okay these types of
people what's the philosophy on the
other side leave me alone let me do my
thing let me live my life don't whether
it's a Libertarian whether it's an
independent anything from Center to the
right it's just leave me alone let me
live the life that I want to live so the
Judgment comes on one bad policies
produce these types of people these
types of people ruin a nation the
ability to want to change these types of
people takes a decade Vinnie in many
instances they don't even know it a lot
of them cannot be saved they won't be
saved we're having a conversation
yesterday about words right the power in
words where it's like hey be careful
saying that because that that statement
doesn't have a lot of weight behind it
right when certain men talk they have
weight behind their words when certain
people talk they don't have weight
behind their words these guys don't have
weight behind their words their words is
what it's not fair that's a weak
statement yeah it's not fair it's not
this it's not that it's not those are
all weak phrases no leader says it's not
fair no independent person says it's not
fair if we simply gauged the weight of
words being used by the left and the
right the level of weakness of the weak
words being used they would be at the
top and this side is going to be more on
this side you know at the bottom they
would lose an amount of weak words to be
used so philosophically if we're talking
about this whole conversation around
what can we do to really change this
like you're asking a question
that's a two decade problem because the
population of acting like victims and
everything else the other person's fault
that population keeps increasing and to
speak to entitlements it's so it's so
apropos like you pose the question to
Myron and Walt yesterday let's go back
to 1963. let's go back in time and what
has changed and we all know the famous
quote from JFK ask not what your country
can do for you ask what you can do for
your country yeah and that is the
antithesis of what entitlement is at
this point what can you give me what can
I get how much money can I get what can
I receive entitlement entitlement
entitlement participation participation
participation and it just goes to show
where the country is gone and how far
left the left has gone where JFK at this
point would be a moderate probably
center-right Republican at this point
and now uh look at us now let's talk
about the dead ceiling let's talk about
the debt ceiling Biden McCarthy reached
that ceiling deal to avoid default and
here's what's in it
um President Joe Biden uh and house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy I've reached a
debt ceiling that is June 5th line Biden
described the bill as a compromise where
no one got everything they wanted the 99
page agreement includes Provisions to
keep non-defense
spending stable in 2024 fiscal year and
increase it by one percent of following
year it also included a two-year debt
limit increase the deal fully funds
Medicare for veterans including 20.3
billion dollar fund for toxic exposure
and expense work requirements for the uh
for the super supplemental nutrition
assistance program snap and snaps with
changes expiring in 2030
uh the agreement resents around 30
billion dollars in unspent coronavirus
relief money while exempting funding for
Veterans Medical Care housing assistant
Indian Health Service and a program for
covid-19 vaccines it introduces changes
to the National Environmental Policy Act
to streamline the process Additionally
the deal ends the pause on student debt
loan repayment within 60 days although
the gop's proposal to rescind the White
House plan to waive student loan that
did not make it into the package the
house is set to vote on the legislation
on Monday so here are six things you
must know from the new debt ceiling from
political number one work requirements
the deal Titans work requirements for
snap and temporary system for needy
families and it introduces new time
limits uh for uh receiving food
assistance affecting individuals up to
54. number two energy permitting the
deal permits mining changes to the
permitting process for energy projects
clean energy funding totaling hundreds
of billions of dollars cover that
clawbacks IRS Cuts what's the IRS cuts
the deal Clause back a portion of the 80
billion dollars in funding to the IRS
the exact amount is not spending
specified but it's relatively small
compared to the Republican demands which
is sought to rescind over 70 billion
dollars snap as spending caps uh they
went from non-defense uh largely flat at
around 637 billion dollars so in other
words the left one and got what they
wanted that's what the negotiation
sounds like defense funding is captured
at the president 86 student loans the
deal preserves President Biden's plan to
cancel student debt up to twenty
thousand dollars the agreement allows
the education department to resume
collecting monthly student loan payments
and interest potentially costing around
eight five million dollars each month so
Tom when you see this here who won this
negotiation uh Democrats did there is no
strong enduring change that's going in
here remember the IRS all those new
agents and all the regulations are going
to go out and do all this and turn the
IRS into a sort of a militarized that
guess what that 80 billion dollars is
still intact uh the thing I read said
that maybe 10 billion dollars was
trimmed off of it remember that 80
billion was new remember all those
agents that they were going to hire and
everything that's all in there so okay
take 10 billion off that but the rest of
it's funded and then you look at the
student loans
um student loans okay you're still going
to 20 000 off the top so the American
taxpayer covers that for everybody that
studied art history or uh you know one
other useless degree feminist Theory
yeah yeah
exactly exactly sitting on debt all the
rest of us are going to take care of
them for twenty thousand dollars and but
they can go back to trying to collect
the um uh the balances from everybody
else and the other part that I I notice
check this out the work requirements in
the needy assistant they expanded and
then but they Sunset the limits in 2030.
what's 20 30 that's two presidential
elections and a midterm away
so there is an intentionality to Kick
the Can on providing entitlement here's
what the Republicans got they got out of
it saying hey we want to reduce all this
dependency money we want to reduce this
entitlement money we want work
requirements so that we do don't
basically it becomes Universal basic
income if you're just giving it to
people and there's no requirement to
work you follow that path it basically
becomes Universal basic income except
all of a sudden you go back and this is
going to expire in 2030. so the
Republicans put an expiration in there
you know what the expiration is two
presidential elections from now it all
goes back to
free money and the the energy permitting
yeah you know minimal changes the
permitting process for energy project
which means it's not allowing Drilling
and expansion of um Shale oil or other
things like that but clean energy gets
its billions which is gonna head right
for the Auto industry at 7 500 bucks a
car if you buy a green car but just
don't try to plug it in California
because when all those people in
California have
electric cars you're going to cause so
in other words Biden is a better
negotiator than McCarthy
yeah yeah somebody got up to the I don't
know if it's Biden is a better
negotiator or there was just more
imagine if you're McCarthy you're in
your 40s 50s you're young for the rest
of your life your legacy is going to say
you couldn't negotiate with an 82 year
old yeah what a freaking great legacy
great job that was 58 years old got out
negotiated by 24 year old older man who
uh has a hard time going up the stairs
false three times but he beats you and
then by the way while you control
Congress yeah while you control it's not
like you didn't have Congress you have
Congress and you were House of represent
and you wouldn't drive it harder to get
what you wanted there's a lot of people
on his camp that are not happy with
their negotiation so the only thing
that's good about this is 30 billion
dollars which was effing pork that was
sitting off to be used for any purpose
whatsoever that was part of the
coronavirus relief that was 30 billion
dollars that the Dems are put in there
to use for anything that got ax that was
a it's called an earmark it was a big
ear Mark and that got pulled out but um
you look at everything that's in here
this is such an opportunity to do things
for the country and they kicked the can
down the road and they gave in on a
bunch of things and
they put up 20 30 deadline and going
back to the American public basically
giving Ubi to a lot of people that are
perfectly able to work and just don't
want to and Biden's going to spend this
obviously Biden's one gonna spin this I
would absolutely of course I mean I mean
spin as in what to say hey we look what
we did yeah of course yeah of course
agreed but by the way I mean If This
Were A Movie if we we've seen the debt
ceiling thing happen year after year you
know every handful of years if this is a
freaking Marvel movie like Tom talks
about it's like the world's coming to an
end we need someone to save us the debt
ceiling's crashing down oh Marvel did it
again thanks Captain America thanks
Superman thanks Batman we all know how
this was going to end thank god
um but it's not like this was gonna they
were gonna let this happen yeah and I
mean I'm not surprised I mean a former
government employee here like the
government operates in what I call
Controlled Chaos you know continuing
resolutions raising the debt ceiling all
the time I think we've done it like 100
times or something like that sounds like
World War II so they're always operating
under okay let's just get this let's
make it to this point and then just
increase it down the road exactly it's
literally quintessential kicking the can
down exactly but at some point
that Road's gonna have to come to an end
the government shut down recycled homie
you know yeah you know the government
shutdowns all that stuff I've been
through several government shutdowns
when I was a an agent and it's just you
know and then here's the thing you're
considered an essential employee when
you're law enforcement yeah so you know
you would still go to work and like all
right I guess I'll get paid an Alum sum
in like a month from now it just kind of
that paycheck's coming just yeah it
comes just not now whenever you have a
government it happened under Trump I
want to say where they yeah they hold
the negotiation with Pelosi and Schumer
and she's like yeah everyone's gonna
blame him
I'll take it and then what we saw happen
is you know 67 of this country lives
paycheck to paycheck yeah including
government employees for sure so when
they don't get their check in two weeks
or in a month oh I remember the crowd
gets Restless the last government
shutdown
um that that went down when I was an
agent like everybody was freaking out
man like oh man what's gonna happen blah
blah this is you know pre-pandemic but
yeah every time it happens like in 18 I
want to say yeah yeah like yep under
under Trump so luckily it didn't last as
long as when it was under Obama but it
happens you know that's what is the
government is perpetually kicking the
can down the road just show what shows
what happens if you rely on the
government yeah we are good things are
not happening polls 66 of Voters say Joe
Biden is too old to serve four more
years a majority of Voters 66 believe
Joe Biden is too old to effectively
serve another four years as president
according to uh quinnipeg poll
Republicans and independent largely hold
this view while Democrats more divided
with 57 saying Biden is not too old
and contrast only 37 percent of
respondents think former president
Donald Trump who is 76 is too old uh for
a second interesting 37 compared to 66
percent uh even though they're only five
years apart age-wise Republicans
Independence lean towards the belief
that Trump is not too old while
Democrats are split on the issue
Washington Post back up backed up focus
group also highlighted negative
assessment of Biden's physical abilities
and mental health with swing state
voters questioning his agents
speculating about dementia can you play
that clip by Jake Tapper please if you
have it
here's Jake Tapper uh uh on the show
yesterday
uh talking about uh uh you just had it
Rob the age
and I just have it a minute ago
I did let me I'll grab it right now you
know what happened when they told when
they asked Joe Biden what he thought
about the poll you know what he said
what are pulse he had no idea what the
hell they were talking about he didn't
see he just walked away he started
shaking hands with the air probably said
I haven't been to a generous club for
many years that's probably right
every president's job
he's like God make it bigger there we go
hilarious as far as I remember and we
plan for helping the Ukrainian can we
play this audio I can't hear it yeah we
played this yet CNN it's fine so
reaction you know they need all the
views they can get facts you can't do
audio
audio is up on my end
okay all right so Tom when you think
about a poll like this how how how
important how critical this is Rob can
you just check to see maybe another clip
can play that how critical is this when
you see 66 number like this is there any
Credence to this poll or is it just
another thing that they're showing here
there's a lot of credence what happens
is remember how bad the pollsters did in
the last two elections how wrong they
were you could take the results of the
election and go down a list of polls and
there were very few of them that were
within their previously stated margin of
error right now so let's separate the
polls and talk about the American psyche
the American psyche right now has seen
Trump on CNN they saw
um DeSantis announce live on Twitter so
the election is at the front of their
mind and so the closer we get to
election the more we get more people
show up in What's called the likely
voters because remember they do the
polls you'll see him that says
registered voters and this was a poll of
likely voters would you say you're a
likely voter yeah I'm pretty pissed off
what I just saw I'm definitely gonna
vote so the likely voters right now have
been activated for the moment and
they've all woked up and said if the
election was hit today you're a likely
voter what would you and everybody's
saying this gosh you know with China
with the economy with everything I I
don't know this is real this is very
real but does it mean that the Dems are
going to pull back on
on the you know the the cardboard cutout
that currently is serving as our
president I don't know if they're going
to do that because they're they're
running the country
behind him right it's a proxy we have we
talk about proxy wars we have to all
understand right now right now we have a
proxy president that's what's going on
right now we need to think about this
and it's not and it's it's it's it's not
Kamala the cop who you know you know
what I feel about her as the AG of
California and the devastation she had
right now people are close Pat and their
their second guessing it and they're
saying I do think age is an issue this
this is very real because the voter for
the moment has been activated this is
all going to subside we're going to go
in the holiday season and then they're
going to pop back up in January but do
you think Tom that the age uh situation
is going to be big enough to have those
voters that we talked about Adam because
you're the Vegas numbers on all the ones
that I looked at has Biden in number one
Biden is the favorite to become the
president do you think that age is
enough because I don't think it's about
the age I believe it's not even about
his policies the voters that are voting
for him are going to vote for not Trump
that's what it's going to be at the end
of the day so it's a not Trump vote you
know how I feel and I think Pat me he'll
speak for himself but I think he's
coming on this page too I believe the
proxy president stays in place until
they decide that the Health crisis is
there I think Michelle steps in and she
is your Democratic Michelle Michelle
might I think she's oh you're saying
that Michelle Obama's gonna step in all
of a sudden yeah I've been dismissing
that here for years at this point I
don't think she thinks she might be the
one
um
to your point on Vegas I think that will
crystallize and be cemented once there's
a candidate from the Republican primary
and then that person whoever it is Trump
to santis will be the favorite uh listen
for anyone that doesn't think that the
age is not a problem you're living in
life
one thing please so
you know what is it 70 66 think that Joe
Biden uh is too old 37 by the way did
you see what number of percentage people
think that Ron DeSantis is too old to
run uh zero nobody that's not a concern
but so I think I've said this before the
juxtaposition if this were the case of
Trump versus Biden on stage we've seen
that movie before we've seen this play
out but Trump I'm sorry DeSantis versus
Biden the the competency and the age
disparity would be so glaring that
DeSantis will just walk his way into the
White House just because you have a 44
year old man versus a 84 year old man
it's so polarizing and such a just
glaring situation whereas Trump is only
four years age difference I don't think
it's going to be that big of a factor
when it comes down to the election time
yeah I mean the the reality here is that
people value they don't value competency
what they value is how the candidate
makes them feel versus the real Trump
elicits a lot of uh you know strong
feelings from people the race is always
an [__] build the wall a little bit
good but at the end of the day was the
United States a better country with him
in office yes it was I mean when I was
an agent and he was uh president were
arrested and taken down some of the
worst people we're putting more
pedophiles in jail we're getting into
more criminal aliens the country was
Stronger when Trump was in office versus
now the guy can barely you know have a
speech ready and or speak coherently
even when there's a teleprompter in
front of him so the thing is is that
people value how they feel about it
Canada over the candidates competency
which goes to show you that we live in a
very [__] stupid world where people
lack critical thinking skills we talk
about this all the time uh policy versus
personality and what do you think most
people vote based on policy no you're
wrong Personality yeah most people are
gonna vote based on you don't like Joe
Biden's policies I don't know what I'm
saying I'm joking most people are one or
two issue voters it's the it's the
economy stupid or it's abortion or it's
immigration or its guns or it's health
care whatever it is they got their one
or two issues that they care about but
they're not going policy by policy
policy by policy they're just like all
right I hate Trump's tweets he's out Joe
Biden's a piece of [__] he's out and
that's just how people vote and and the
thing also is that like you know people
went off after Trump for the you know
grab her by the [__] comment blah blah
blah we're talking about a clip that was
over a decade ago it was locker room
talk when he was you know a star Etc and
if you don't think that men talk like
this behind the scenes then you're just
not living in reality of anything I want
a president I'm able to relate to I'm
able to sit there and have a
conversation with I love watching
Trump's interviews like he did with full
Senate Etc you can see that the guy is a
personable guy people can hate him
whatever it may be but regardless you
got to take out his personality okay is
he a good president did he do good
things he did it's it's pretty much
irrefutable but people are more
concerned with how Trump makes them feel
yeah versus what he's doing on the real
hard to separate that's exactly right it
takes a deep crisis of a Nation to get
people think about the real yeah but
during a deep crisis they will I saw
polls
um that were like 90 days after 9 11 are
you glad George Bush is president or
would you have preferred Al Gore it was
shocking it was all the way over why
because probably 90 something percent
exactly at that point because you know
what they were thinking they were going
about thinking wait do I want Gore the
hand ringer pacing around the Oval
Office or I want the knee Breakers here
and Dick Cheney was seen as a knee
breaker and so people were all lined up
with you know what but it takes a crisis
like that to get people to go to the
real otherwise it's perception political
but it also he was even Jake Tapper from
CNN watch this when he had to give this
poll horrible news horrible for Joe
Biden I'm so sorry
go back please I can't hear anything you
guys are talking over it's 15 seconds go
ahead horrible news horrible for Joe
Biden our new CNN Paul while the
president leads his Democratic
competitors by a huge margin two-thirds
of all of the American people surveyed
66 of the public say that Biden Victory
would either be a setback or a disaster
for the United States
that's not a script by the way he's
getting more credible incredible by the
day by the hour Jake Tapper wait is that
news or is he making an apology Jake
Tapper was like making apology yeah dude
he said he said horrible twice horrible
news horrible for Joe Biden I'm shocked
that even they didn't cut him off can
you just give CNN credit for a second
for years they were feeding us nonsense
and this is actual it's not CNN that's
what I'm saying I'm giving him Credit
Credit not CNN give Jake credit for the
work that he's done here here and by the
way he cannot stand Donald Trump no he
cannot stand I am willing to bet deep
down inside he is hoping DeSantis
becomes his presence for sure yes I am
hoping deep down inside he's sitting
there saying please get this uh you know
biting guy out I don't want the other
guy in let's get somebody like a
DeSantis in I think that's who he would
want and a lot of guys in his world
would rather have a DeSantis than a
Biden or a trump I think guys like him
would rather have a descent in a uh or a
trump or Biden yeah well CNN for the
Rainy spot they better hope Trump like
they need controversy because CNN has
just been going there in another town
hall yeah Trump revitalized them with
that oh man what a generous guy yeah
what a nice guy dude he's such a that's
that's he's a good good-hearted guy and
the thing is this right people are going
to say the things that they want to say
about Trump the point is this he doesn't
Biden has not faced the same level of
scrutiny that Trump did if you if we had
Trump's family right involved in all the
nefarious acts that the Biden families
involved in doing Shady deals with Dinah
with China accepting money from foreign
Nationals
um all these cell companies
[Music]
yeah if all this stuff was associated
with with Trump they would have buried
him further but you don't see them
mainstream media covering that with all
the nefarious links to the Biden
organization oh my God bro if it was a
DOT if it was a Donald Trump Junior
laptop well under it would be over
smoking crack underage Chinese girls all
the are you kidding me bro
dude you want to know how I know that
they just have a hard on for Trump but
they're trying to get him on anything
they indicted him up in New York and I
don't know if you were going to talk
about this it stop me if you guys were
they didn't add them up in New York so
Alvin Bragg attorney general out there
went ahead and indicted him for
falsifying business records which by the
way guys is a [__] misdemeanor okay
but they went ahead and hit him with the
felony because they think it's going to
be in furtherance of a felony which I'm
looking at my head like wait he paid off
a porn star uh his attorney and already
ended up getting charged for that
federally Etc whatever now the state of
New York and that's what Alvin Brad
campaigned under by the way I'm gonna go
after Trump I'm gonna go after Trump and
the best he could do was a falsifying
business records which is typically a
misdemeanor charge but he went ahead and
tried to enhance it to the felony on
site of oh it's a furtherance of another
crime which I think they might try to
use the uh you know donating to
um campaign over exceeding the funds as
the subsequent crime which doesn't make
sense because that's a federal crime
that's a whole other thing but they just
have a hard-on from you know the the
lawsuit right which I actually read the
lawsuit on air it's written as a novel
it's not written as a legal document
it's literally I want you guys go on
Pacer look at 50 Shades of Gray type
that's literally a 50 Shade it's a great
thing and the woman that made the
allegations
basically her strong her case was on her
testimony and two other witnesses that
she called right after the act so and
everyone's running around saying Trump
is guilty of sexual assault no he was
found liable in a civil court it is not
the same thing preparedness of the
evidence as a far smaller burden than it
is beyond a reasonable doubt but the
court of me you know public opinion
wants you to say oh you got convicted of
sexual assault no that is not true he
was found liable and it doesn't take
much proof in a civil case to prove 51
versus 49 essentially
did you see the the interview with the
lady with Anderson Cooper says so were
you physically raped oh my God no listen
rape is not physical
rape can be emotional rape can be and
Anderson Cooper have you seen this or no
yeah I haven't seen this but it sounds
can you please find that clip do you
know which one I'm talking about
emotional rape emotional but have you
seen this no oh my goodness because it's
the funniest part about this is how
uncomfortable Anderson Anderson right
there if you can oh my God zoom out a
little bit who's this girl so this is
the lady this is the girl that says a
trump raped her okay watch this go ahead
you don't feel like a victim I was not
thrown on the ground and ravish which
the word rape carries so many sexual
connotation this was not this was not
sexual for it just it it hurt it just
what it just you know I think most
people think of rape as a I mean it is a
violent assault it is not I think most
people think of rape as being sexy
what let's make a short break of the
fantasies listen
we're just going to take a quick break
listen what she says you're fascinating
to talk to listen oh my God
[Music]
I forgot to mention one thing for you
when I read through this document right
yeah clown world [__] clown world
this woman by the way just so you guys
know when she made the allegation right
against Trump that he he graped her in
this uh in this store right out in uh
out in New York City Manhattan what she
basically did was she went ahead and
released it first in a newspaper okay
she released that part of her book in
the newspaper then she went ahead and
released the book and did a tour you're
telling me that this woman was actually
assaulted as she claims but she
conveniently go ahead it goes ahead and
puts this out right before while Trump
is campaigning and also when she's right
in the middle of a book tour and the
Harvey Weinstein stuff was popping off
like come on man like perfect timing
like what what's going on and the
craziest thing is Myron people well like
they'll just say they won't they don't
go they don't dig deep right yeah
they're just like he raped her you
didn't hear he had pinned her down and
Trump raped her in some Lobby and this
is the girl like like he raped her how
emotionally what did he do he just just
being there she felt like violated I'm
so confused that's the problem we don't
use static terms with a lot of these
liberal retards out on the left they
want to go ahead and say stupid [__]
like I feel like I was raped before he
raped me emotionally no it's penetration
against your will stupid okay that's
what it is that if you're if we're gonna
go ahead and make serious allegations
about people well we need serious
definitions on what the [__] we're
actually talking about but over there on
that side of the internet they want to
use ambiguous terms like sexual assault
and I felt this way or blah blah blah
regret is not rape but that's the
problem is that people feel like they
can go ahead and retroactively withdraw
consent and it's getting into a very
scary situation now where guys are gonna
that have any type of status whatever
you need to make these girls sign ndas
or consent forms or whatever because
they're coming after the fact 20 30. 50
years later right saying oh this
happened to me blah blah blah to go
ahead and push a [__] book yeah yeah
by the way if you show this video of
this lady again who does this lady
remind uh what's her name flavor flaves
uh no ex-wife you've seen 40 year old
virgin yeah with the the you have that
picture I sent you the one that works
the manager yeah she's like you're
fascinating I'm gonna put some blush on
you real quick I could tell she's in
another world dude the clown World by
the way what's embarrassing it's
definitely uncomfortable yeah totally
what's what's embarrassing is how
uncomfortable Anderson Cooper was
exactly and how quickly the producer
told him commercial
ASAP this is embarrassing wow and then
the clips gone viral all over the place
okay I'm surprised the first time you're
seeing this yeah absolute embarrassing
when you see her make the argument that
rapist not physical yeah
she saw books though so sometimes
so he so this is what he got in trouble
for New York and he's he's in court and
everything it's for this person this is
one of them oh my god listen their their
goal is to do whatever they can for this
guy not to run that's what their goal
it's so obvious it's a targeted attack
when I read that lawsuit and that
complaint and then saw when she filed it
she claims this happened back in the
freaking 90s yet she comes out with it
you know right before she puts out a
book and here's the other thing if you
had really been assaulted like that
right why would you take that part of
your book specifically and put it out in
the public in the newspaper to see how
people respond to it as soon as people
respond to favorably okay I'm dropping a
book and then Boom book tour right after
no one questions any of this stuff and
it's like dude is she serious but that's
why she went to a civil court versus a
criminal yeah just a Playbook an
unassailable victimhood is what we have
now that's what we have now the
unassailable victimhood you can claim
victimhood on anything and the only way
to make that work is ambiguity ambiguity
of Defense genders ambiguity of
artifactus ambiguity of what rapist and
isn't now you have unassailable
victimhood this is a Playbook ladies and
gentlemen folks didn't we talk about
this earlier the words we came up with
so qualities of the most annoying people
in the world victim oil on there
complainer ungrateful
leachers modern day women crab magnet
what's the next one here is entitled
bitter nagger I mean this is this is
these are all elements and qualities of
that and she shows some of those
qualities let's go to the next story The
Santa's is going after Trump like never
before this is a CNN story
uh uh uh let's see here so Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis now Canada for
president has openly criticized foreign
calling him fiscally irresponsible a
supporter of amnesty for undocumented
immigrants and blaming him for
destructive covid-19 policies DeSantis
aims to flex the powers of the
presidency like never before intending
to fire Trump's handicapped FBI director
Chris Ray on his first day if elected he
believes Trump has changed since his
2015-2016 campaign and asks questions I
don't know what happened to Donald Trump
The Scientist by the way that's a very
good strategy the Santa's plans to push
the limits on the executive branch using
his knowledge of the Constitution
leverage points and the true scope of
presidential powers to accomplish this
goals he wants to discipline the
bureaucracy dispel the notion of
independent agencies and issue pardons
for cases involving political targeting
of open weaponization so check this out
that whole concept of I don't know what
happened to Donald Trump of 2016 2015
he said the other day one of the things
he's been talking about is Trump keeps
going further left oh yeah Trump keeps
going further left I actually think
that's powerful to make that statement
and in shows in Florida Dead Heat raised
between DeSantis and Trump Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis and former
president Donald Trump are tied in a
neck and neck contest among likely GOP
Primary voters in Florida according to
recent poll conducted by Victory
insights DeSantis narrowly leads with
38.2 percent while Trump follows closely
at 38 percent in a head-to-head matchup
between the santis and Trump the
governor holds a slightly stronger
position with just over 40 percent
compared to Trump 39 the poster senior
poster Ben gulbright acknowledges the
uncertainty regarding the durability of
those results He suggests that the
scientists surge in the post maybe
temporary reaction to his campaign
launch or it could slightly it could
signify signify the beginning of a
successful campaign the outcome of the
nomination May change on Florida
Republican voters as a leaked audio from
donor meeting reveals the importance of
winning the state's winner takes off
presidential preference primary schedule
for March 19th of next year what do you
think of when you see this Myron
foreign
it's crazy man because it's going to
cause divide
um I think the thing is is that you know
the census obviously is very uh people
love them down here in Florida but I
don't know if the rest of the country
knows about him like that so
um yeah I I wish they would they would
collaborate and work together and uh you
know take over the Biden Administration
but you know that's not going to happen
because now at this point it's kind of
in the court of public appeals and
they've been making fun of each other
and you know Trump's been poking fun at
him so yeah we're past that but Byron do
you think that they can't do what the
what the Democrats do we talked about
this the last podcast Biden and Kamala
went at it but right when it was done
he's like I love you vice president
there's zero chance that that happens if
Trump wins because it's not going to go
the other way around it's possible but
not not probable is what I is what I
think just because it's been kind of
them just [__] on each other the
whole time and even even Trump's been
he's been going pretty hard at DeSantis
and so yeah and Kamala was never on
Biden's level I mean she was of course
she was punching up he was like all
right cool whatever I gotta I gotta
cross off a African-American woman a
maker vice president you're one of four
people that are candidates and if you
kiss the ring so to speak I'll give that
the political move exactly there's a
political move that's what he did so in
your definition she's is not
African-American right so she's making
it Jamaican Indian America yeah sure by
the way have you ever seen Kamala when
she was dating Montel Williams a month
went to an event with two women gangster
her being one of them have you seen it
yeah yeah
was with her and another girl and went
to an event look at that Pam look at
that pimp well listen uh chilling
there's plenty of pictures on the
internet with me and two girls
you're not the vice president no you're
not uh Kamala Harris that's uh and uh
you know Montel when Montel was running
the number one by the way what's so
funny is is that a cross he's wearing is
that a soul I think it's a sword okay I
was gonna say it's actually probably
it's a cross sword it's probably one of
those cocaine uh sifters you just unplug
it it gives me Cruel Intentions can I
say one thing about DeSantis
um
it's interesting because I don't think
there's there's going to be some
cohesion there I think that's I think
that's I wish I wish too I think that's
too far gone it was interesting I was I
watched the Heat game but I was shout
out to the heat
um uh I was watching it was game five it
was a few nights ago I was with all my
buddies from that I grew up with in
Miami you've known these guys yeah yeah
all um this segment of my of my friends
they're all liberals all of them okay so
safe space yeah safe space so I come in
late you know because I was working late
that day and I walk in they're like oh
look who's here Mr Maga Mr right wing
I'm like so it just shows like as a
registered independent like you can't
win these days no if I go into right
wing circles I'm the soy boy I'm the I'm
the leftist the Communist and if I go
into left-wing circles I'm the mag I'm
the Trump I was like listen guys there's
no way relax for a second but I said is
anybody here a trump fan no [__] Trump
trump I go all right
um
none of these guys are voting in the
Republican primary but I know I get this
is anecdotal but I said all right
uh if you had to choose between Trump
and DeSantis who would you vote for 10
guys okay these are never trumpers what
do you think the results of my internal
poll was eight to two DeSantis I was in
six seven three
six four seven three this answers to
Trump okay Trump trump seven the same
yeah three Tom uh I'm gonna go also six
four to Santa it was split down the
middle oh God so just for some
perspective these guys who never I have
to meet these guys yeah because at this
point I'm not I'm not sure
they're telling you they do and they
would never in a million years vote for
Trump but that's in their mind how low
does Santa says well and they're all
Florida Miami-Dade guys but you know
well they think this is popular here in
Florida but I just don't know if the
rest of the country is gonna you know it
knows who he is or cares you know
obviously Trump is the more polarizing
figure he's you know he he's more
marketable right and Trump did a
fantastic job when he campaigned before
make America great again you know
because his business that you know being
a president is advertising you know
making fun of Hillary lock her up you
know crooked Hillary Etc like all these
memorable moments do you have all any of
these like memorable moments with these
other guys like Obama when he campaign
change right like he was real big on
Words yes we can so um the the
presidents that typically win especially
in in the social media age are the
better marketers they say that um you
know for every business you either have
a product problem or a marketing problem
I think we know what Ron DeSantis
problem is it's a marketing problem and
my trump don't got that problem yeah it
might be made a good point because like
the the country doesn't really know who
DeSantis is yeah but the left has put
out those little markers of don't say
gay Bill he hates gays and the NAACP
just put out that thing that said
warning don't come here because they're
actively going after black people it's
like come on boys so the country knows
of him as being Florida as being like
like a Nazi don't like don't come here
you know what I mean and all these polls
that are behind all of this this is
right now what we have is they are pop
activity polls right you have a little
activity and you have a pop you have a
little activity you're gonna have a drop
so you're gonna have a little activity
pop little activity drop and that's why
uh Victory insights pollster Ben
Galbraith was saying hey we really don't
know about the durability of the pole
what he's saying that the durability of
it is like hey three weeks from now
somebody's going to make a little verbal
Gaff and then it's going to pop the
other way Americans aren't going to wake
up and be really pullable mark my words
until the morning after the Collegiate
national championship game that way all
New Year's is over all the all the games
the ball's over and we are into the
serious part of the year I believe we're
going to be in the recession there and
the people are going to wake up and go
wait a minute we really get it we really
have to do this and you're going to have
Iowa South Carolina and New Hampshire
lining right up until then we're going
to see pup and Drop pop and Drop pop and
drop okay all right let's go to the next
time
in the morning baby Elon Musk neural
link wins FDA approval for human study
of four of brain implants this is a
Reuters
story
um Vinnie I heard you were like getting
uh you know like asking to be early I
wanted to be one of the first humans has
received the approval for the first
human struggling a significant
achievement for brain implants startup
uh amidst uh uh ongoing investigations
into its animal experiments in recent
weeks the FDA has not inspected New
Orleans laboratory practices despite
concerns raised by employees and experts
Victor
crowdermeyer a former FDA official
stated that the FDA should have verified
the reliability of New Orleans animal
study results before proven human trials
musk's envisions the brain implants as a
potential cure for various conditions
and has expressed confidence in their
safety even offering to implant them in
his own children the FDA
um the FDA had previously highlighted
safety concerns regarding the device's
lithium battery wire migration within
the brain and safe extraction without
damage and brain
tissue so can you run a poll run a poll
saying how many of you would be open to
the idea of going on first trial testing
to have this chip neural linked chip put
into your brain just curious to know
what percentage is going to say yes and
it's more than a chip it's wires wiring
in your brain and I just thought it
might remind you Elon musk's awesome
space traveling doing all this all this
stuff he's doing bought the Twitter it
might be a wolf in sheep's clothing bro
this thing is I don't notice this all
happened uh the FDA approval happened on
the day that they did the whole thing
with DeSantis they went live all that
stuff bro they can't even do the live
event right you want to put a freaking
they want to put wires in your brain I
just don't who's to know that at one
point they have all this [__] in your
head that they could put [__] in there
to control your assets that they want
you to do I don't trust that all we've
read we're Christians in the Bible I've
always read mark of the beast Market the
Beast it's when stuff is going to start
being put inside you is when it's game
over I don't trust it the FDA pad they
halted a bunch of stuff because
thousands and thousands of animals pigs
were dying they were failed testing the
animals were tripping out they just
killed they just killed the animal I
think they're gonna be testing on people
that are have extreme physical problems
which at that point they're like listen
this person's they'd rather be dead than
you know be in the state that they're in
go ahead test them to see if you could
fix their problems
on Thursday okay
musk the rest of quote he said I invite
other presidential candidates to join me
on Twitter spaces and so that we can
make their opinions known to the
American people and I would like to
offer Joe Biden a neural link test at no
charge oh really yes but no charge
they're gonna test his brain everybody
else can come on Twitter spaces and then
Biden he'll give them the neural link
chip at no charge well by the time you
say stuff like that you're a pretty
serious guy he's joking yeah
Elon Musk is putting the chip into
Biden's uh brain I think I don't trust a
lot of people are going to sign up for
this thing I just don't trust it I think
aside from the people that you know
the people who find it necessary that
people with major uh nervous system
issues mental health disorders what have
you I think these people do it no I'm
out on that but I think people are so
young people especially permanently out
on them I'm out uh no no hang on a
second are you permanent good being a
human meaning five ten years never say
never but I'm in the never camp for
right now okay because you know I want
to hear that I'm probably in the never
camp but I'll have to say this five
percent opening there probably I went to
school with a guy that got the external
it's basically
um the external hearing technology you
know that actually you've seen you've
seen people yeah and it's amazing it was
absolutely amazing I mean it's this wire
that goes in there in a Cochlear and
plant that's inside your ear and then
you know that it just it changed his
life so I've seen technology firsthand
do that and I was completely blown away
and I was first thinking how you're
going to walk around this thing but it
was such a a life changer for the guy
and so I I think that's probably the
path we're going to go on here
ultimately how about you when are you
signing up for this thing definitely not
but this is how they're going to get it
streamlined out they're gonna
incentivize people by paying them money
to do it of course whether it's going to
be some kind of stimuli check or hey
we'll give you 510k go ahead uh you know
we'll give you this money right away
tax-free just put this chip in your head
and it's going to be the beginning of I
think the government's going to pay or a
private company
it could be it could be both it could be
where the government promises it and
backs in then the government and then
they go ahead and you know reimburse the
private company for doing so so I mean I
wouldn't be surprised I mean I wouldn't
know Pat what about you I want to work
because Pat hit me up yeah right now
right now Myron it's for people that you
know like they have strokes they can't
use their hands what they're saying is
you're going to be able to basically
download French and have like if
somebody's speaking to you in French
you understand it fluently in your ear
through this thing and who knows what
the the future is going to be bro you
could download like in The Matrix
remember when they're like a helicopter
she's gonna fly the helicopter yes
but again it's it's who controls that
download at what point could just put
out a massive hey all of you idiots now
you're our slaves period I don't trust
them I think the guy is brilliant I
don't trust that [__] they're gonna
Target the susceptible people the poor
the weak the sick hey put this chip it's
gonna make your life better and they
don't got nothing to lose and they're
gonna get some money out of it so
they're gonna do
and it's coming from Elon he's the
savior of free speech he put you know he
has spaceships landing back on it I
don't I don't trust it sorry yeah so
you're canceling your Thursday
appointment Thursday's finished okay you
guys just talked me out again what's the
poll so far what's the poll so far let's
see the poll
I'm curious uh no good job guys 800 said
no 11 said yes that 11 is like let's go
refresh you're supposed to refresh on
let's see what that poll is refresh uh
uh to see where it's at now I'm getting
into it seriously so 89 are saying no no
89 is still the same 89 11. okay all
right 1200 votes legit 89 saying no 11
saying yes to the 11 that are saying yes
why yes to the 11. that's a big
percentage to say yes so why yes is this
you know you know what it's like like I
remember in in uh uh a part of in the
company insurance company we had a
movement going on where guys were taking
uh what is the thing you take in school
to help you study better yeah
so people were calling me hey what do
you think that guy over there in that
office taking Adderall that's helping
them focus better on this I'm like
listen dude here's all you need to know
I don't take Adderall I don't like this
I don't like that I don't anything that
controls me I'm not a fan of like I
don't want any of that stuff
but look a lot of people did
I got add my doctor told me I got add so
this Adderall thing is really helping me
out like all right dude you keep telling
yourself that you're right you believe
it you know if you wanna if you want to
do something like that go for it so
there's gonna be a camp
of people who are going to history tells
us
you know anything that's come to
expedite and speed up the process of
getting something without having to work
hard for it there's a long line of
people that open today why would there's
a big market for that right so you know
the movie nzt I'll never forget the
Limitless movie remember the Limitless
was sick by the way this is the my first
ever piece of content that went viral do
you know the story you know the story so
the movie comes out and I had a website
called
patrickbetdavidblog.com can you go to it
I don't even know if it's around go to
Patrick davisblog.com and see if it
exists where does it go somebody
probably bought it pat yeah okay so it
doesn't exist so we had this block and I
would write something once every other
week
so it's 2012. check to see one Limitless
came out the night it came out I wrote
this article I'm actually curious to
know this was one of my first five
pieces of content I ever wrote 2011. I
wrote it the night it came out go to the
day it came out do you know what a day
came out anyways so I write this article
and I write okay March 8th so March 8th
I write the article that seven years ago
okay so I write the article did Einstein
use nzt and where to get it okay so then
I write and all this stuff you know in
life everybody's looking for shortcuts
and all this stuff but what if there was
a way to get in ZT would you use it I go
to sleep I wake up in the morning these
things at the top of Google I have ten
thousand thousands of emails asking me
do you know where I can get NCT from I
said I know nothing about MGT it's just
an article I wrote yeah but it was the
power of the internet how an article can
get viral it just tells you how many
people watch the movie and they're also
interested in this nzt this was the
article right whatever I wrote in this
article 12 years ago
the moral of the story is what there's a
massive market for people who want
things without the hard work that is not
going to go away and I'm telling you so
many people are going to subscribe to
these chips because every time they got
a new upgrade they gotta know like you
know the whole Tesla that automatically
upgrades the new upgrade to the brain
the new upgrade we have this a new
upgrade to this oh my God so so now
watch I'm like there's going to be like
a thousand kids in high school 920 of
them have a 4.5 GPA oh yeah so so
education goes berserk this thing can
come right yeah because they're like why
am I needed exactly why do you even need
me comedians are going out there and
chat GPT say can you give me a money log
on this and tell this joke and the style
of how this Comedian says that come in
and boom let me clean it up add my own
words to it and go out there and read it
right so if this thing does what it's
capable of doing with the upgrades why
do we need school why do we need to go
to high school why do we need to go to
college what do you need it for you need
information just get the link that's all
it is it's a very interesting direction
we're going into because you know during
covet when people were saying uh uh uh
some people had on their profiles where
people were buying uh men's
who hadn't taken a vaccine and pure
Bloods were the pure Bloods yeah from
buying again girls were dying to get
sperm from 400 bucks didn't take vaccine
right I didn't take that like me ladies
yeah anyway so this is almost like a a
camp of people dating each other who
don't have the you know chip in their
head so you can actually talk to
somebody normally yeah where it's not
like knowing all you're like hey are you
chipped no okay let's uh let's have a
talk and the reason why this thing is
going to be successful unfortunately I
hate to say it like that is because
human beings always strive to go the
path of least resistance right you look
at you know people go ahead and get
gastro bypass surgery right because
they're fat this is going to be more on
bypass surgery where people are going to
be able to get some tips in their hand
and be able to like oh now I can speak
another language oh now I'm a critical
thinker I'm no longer a [__] like
people are gonna go ahead and do this
because they're like I'm an idiot so let
me go ahead and get this chip in my head
so I can not look like as much of an
idiot but that's what it is people
people are just lazy we live in a very
instant gratification Uber Eats type
Society where people don't want to
necessarily work for certain things
imagine if everybody had a six-pack
what's the big deal about having a six
pack nothing it doesn't matter if
everybody was shredded and cut up what's
the big deal it's no longer attractive
to be that right it's the complete
opposite if everybody if you right now
if I ask you right now you know what day
did John F Kennedy graduate from high
school and you know who was his best
friend if you're right oh my God it's
not even fun okay so what is the fun
aspect there's none what makes it fun is
when we can study people who can
naturally compete at a high level to see
who can get to that performance of
competition naturally yeah the moment
you take that natural method of
competition competition out
if you if you beat me you didn't beat me
naturally there's no uh uh there's no
Maritime there's no meritocracy but
there's no like man I'm impressed by
this guy right yeah so it's gonna look
I'm not impressed by you you're a chip
you're not talking it's the chip talking
yeah there's nothing impressive about
you what's impressive is the chip you
got yeah that's an impressive chip but
not you so you actually lose identity
but again
will it be a trillion dollar business
here's another thing two people need to
understand most people are literally
stupid like I think people need to
understand that like the common American
is a functioning [__] like they are
stupid
[__] okay [__] right a [__] [__]
um but like the point is is that people
especially nowadays right they lack
critical thinking skills yeah they're
not able to look at something question
it come to their own conclusion they're
gonna go ahead and go with what everyone
else says people are sheep nowadays so
you know this chip is just going to
allow people not only to be controlled
but it's going to help them not I guess
help them not be as big of idiots what's
normal what's neural Link's uh stock
price right now Rob because I'm just not
to cut you off that I'm curious because
it's I mean there it just got approved
so I'm curious to how where it's at and
where it's going to be going I don't
think it's public yet is it not public
no I don't believe it is but what I will
say is it's fake success we talk about
this all the time where uh the tale of
time will actually reveal who has the
success it's steroids for the brain and
we all know that steroids doesn't have a
happy ending it's also stimulus for the
economy it's participation trophies for
every other kid out there uh there's
going to be an unhappy ending at the end
of this for somebody
yeah so so let's go to hiring hey at our
company what are the benefits you guys
offer we give you the latest version CRX
uh to uh ee Edition 72 uh it's a 220 000
chip that we have uh one of the benefits
we offer is everybody that starts with
us we put that chip in you and we
Finance it for you oh wow what a big
benefit but then when you leave you have
to give that chip back oh no see that's
a form of a retention
forget about 401K forget about this
immediately you're going to be at the
top of your game working with our
company because we have the best chip in
the marketplace wow people are dumb now
without a chip could you imagine you
give the chip then you take it back oh
my God
because that whole time that you had
that chip that the whole time you've had
that chip your brain hasn't been yeah
it's not developed you haven't learned
how to you know independently research
talk to people you're literally
everybody
page 13 top
we're about to get canceled I hope not
so what you guys are talking about with
the chip
to get hired you can't just be dumb you
can't sound dumb so basically a Southern
accent read the article Billy Joe and
Jim Bob
a study conducted by the University of
Chicago and the University of Munich
revealed that job Seekers with the
southern accent may experience a wage
penalty potentially earning thousands of
dollars less per year the research
indicated that individuals with strong
Regional access particularly Southern
Accents could facial weight penalty of
up to 20 compared to those with standard
accent another study conducted by the
writing tips Institute found that 38 of
job Seekers admitted to modifying their
accent during an interview due to
negative stereotypes the study
identified the profession with job
applicants are more likely to change
their accents as real estate tourism
Public Service Information Technology
you know science engineering Hospitality
Finance retail Healthcare and media you
sound like a stupid Blaster Tom you
sound like a dumb bastard I'm sorry I'm
telling you right now there's a lot of
Truth sometimes the truth hurts I you
know so when the South you know I went
to college in Florida State and there's
some there's seven people out there I
also went to college my freshman year I
played football at Greensboro North
Carolina I I hung out there there's a
difference between Southern Charm and
southern hospitality and being a
Southern Belle and there's all that yeah
and then you have Senator John Kennedy
out of Louisiana oh my God he's the [__]
that guy went to law school UVA and he
sounds like this he goes yeah you're
stupid I'm talking to you out here and
it just it's something that dog don't
huh yeah no no go back there not sound
exactly well the last thing look can you
imagine going against surgery open up
surgery and the doctor's like all right
we're gonna open you up get in your rap
ventricle I'm like nah dude I'm good
yeah I want to get the hell out of here
I'll go to New York the most difficult
accent to deal with this vacation oh
yeah uh sorry coach uh I'm gonna get
some water for you all right
yeah I can understand why those people
are underappreciated but don't you know
don't judge a book by its cover this
guy's actually a sharp Guy funny dude
but now you're no but now what your chip
could do your chip could do in terms of
linguistics and language skills it
erases us right you get your chip and
then you get your neutral accent you
sound a little bit smarter and you get
the job I wouldn't be shouted if that
happened to him he's like from the Bayou
Louisiana but now he's all smart he's a
senator yeah all right let's go to the
next door here last story here that was
good Lindsey Graham says Russians dying
is the best thing best money to US U.S
spend uh uh and this could potentially
get him a death threat if it hasn't
already so speaking about something can
you pull up the video I think we do have
the video if you got the Lindsey Graham
video you have it in your notes is that
the one okay let's just play this here's
Lindsey Graham
now you are free yes and we will be and
the Russians are down so the best money
we've ever spent yes thank you so much
no it's free dude wow that is like that
is that's evil pack that's that's
straight up yeah so let me just read it
I made a shocking remarks during a
meeting with Ukrainian president
zielinski and the Russians are dying
it's the best money we've ever spent
grammar uh Graham urges a Biden
Administration to increase Aid to
Ukrainian Express support for the
international fighter jet Coalition that
will provide F-16 Jersey emphasized the
significant significance of providing
more weapons to Ukraine stating F-16
will matter it'll be decisive Russia's
ambassador to UK
under a Kellen warned of an escalation
in the war in Ukraine as Western allies
commit more weapons I'll read the
follow-up to this and then Myra I'm
going to come to you first on this one
so Russia issues Lindsey Graham arrest
warrant after Ukraine comments Kremlin
spokesman Dimitri peskov commented
Sunday by saying that it is hard to
imagine a greater shame for the country
that having such Senators according to
the Associated Press Russia's
investigative committee moved to open a
criminal investigations against Graham
in the interior Ministry followed up
with a warrant for his arrest Graham
considers the arrest warrant to be a
badge of honor to know that my
commitment to Ukraine has drawn the ire
of Putin's regime brings me immense Joy
I will continue to stand with and for
Ukraine's Freedom until every Russian
soldier is expelled from Ukrainian
territory Graham said in their statement
Monday finally here's an offer to my
Russian friends who want to arrest and
try me for calling out Putin regime as
being war criminals I will submit to
jurisdiction of the international
criminal court if you do he added come
and make your best case see you in Hague
Myron
this isn't our business I mean what I
mean by that is the United States should
not have intervened in this situation
people don't understand that Ukraine
used to be a part of the USSR and the
thing is is that people don't understand
is that and I have to give this
equivalency for Americans so they
understand because a lot of them don't
understand geopolitics the same degree
what's going on with Ukraine right now
is the equivalent to like let's say
China decided to go ahead and have
missiles in Mexico pointing at the
United States we would be in Mexico
tomorrow to get those Chinese out that's
essentially what happened with the
Russians and uh Ukraine with NATO and uh
you know Russia Boone's been warning
them forever hey you know NATO's trying
to encroach on Ukraine you better not
let them in better not let them in if
they come in we're going to have
problems and you know zielinski kept
flirting with NATO and they came in and
what did Boone do okay well now we're
gonna return on force and my thing is
I'm not on either side but I understand
where poon is coming from because he's
operating to protect his country he's
operating to protect his National
Security and a lot of Americans don't
understand that the United United States
would do the same exact thing if our
enemy came into Mexico or came to us in
a position where they're at an advantage
where they can point missiles out of so
I look at it like when you're talking
about geopolitics you're talking about
war you're talking about National
Security Etc every country is going to
do what's best in their interests and
it's crazy to me how we can invade
somewhere like Iraq right and for no
real reason right we had a bunch of
propaganda after 9 11 people don't even
know that Bin Laden and Saddam Hussein
didn't even like each other let alone
were allies but we went ahead and used
that excuse of 9 11 to go ahead and
invade Iraq and then no one said
anything to us but if poone goes into
Ukraine which was a part of the USSR and
their serious
um ramifications for NATO being there to
their National Security we're over here
complaining up in arms it's not our
business we need to focus our problems
at home not necessarily Ukraine and I'm
not saying that's in so anyone that it
might be Ukrainian or whatever it may be
but you got to understand that every
country is going to operate in their own
best interest for National Security
Myron's 100 right the US has some
experience with this it's called the
Cuban Missile Crisis is
yes yes but I just I just think Lindsey
Graham like to say something like that
but to say and the Russians are dying he
didn't in a sense because dude innocent
people die all the time and Wars it's
the best money we've spent it's you're
Lindsay he's that's a soulless warmonger
saying some stupid [__] like that yeah
like try saying that to the mother or
like even the young soldiers that are
just they have to fight they're forced
to fight for him to say that bro that
guy lost all credibility he didn't have
that much to begin with but what a
scumbag bro to say that [__] just right
in front of the camera I'm wondering at
this point how much he's owned by the
military induction that's what I was
gonna say next yeah because you're
making comments like that it's like
you're a scumbag dude I mean you're a
representative of the United States
you're a senator I mean and now he's got
a warrant out first arrest in Russia
look we've had this debate whether we
should be in Ukraine or not there's pros
there's cons I get all that I think at
this point
what's the exit strategy because if this
turns into another Afghanistan where
where they're in Ukraine for 20 years
yeah I think the American does not have
the wherewithal or or the
just the temperance to even deal with
another War like this again we have so
many freaking issues at home how can we
de-escalate this and get us too like
this is 100 like I said before right A
lot of the times we don't wage war like
we did in World War II we do it through
proxies whether we're aiding the side
that is uh fighting people that we don't
like or we're using spies or Etc or
using intelligence agencies to do things
right now a lot of these documents are
becoming Declassified from the CIA NSA
Etc of all the crap that they did back
in the 40s 50s and 60s and people like
whoa what's going on they were trying to
do my control whatever yes and you don't
think that they're still doing this type
of crap nowadays they're doing it even
more so because we're not going to the
battlefield and fighting we're doing
other things and this war right now with
Ukraine is absolutely excuse me this war
with Russia through the United States
through Ukraine as a proxy is absolutely
a test to see okay let's test some of
our new weapons let's see what's going
on here it funds the military industrial
complex because they need War to make
money very interesting that we're kind
of spending on this story because we
talked about entitlement and as I said
how much entitlement moment do you think
Vladimir zielinski has in the United
States what do you mean you're not
giving more money you're not giving me
more weapons you're not giving me more
artillery all right come on let's go I'm
entitled to this well of course he said
it he said it like a couple months ago
he's like exactly guys we need more
money meanwhile look at all the [__]
that's happening here with veterans and
everything people
billions and billions bro we're
America's second and Ukraine the
mainstream media doesn't want to report
this either they're getting decimated
Russia has been taking ground and
they're doing it slow and methodically
because at the end of the day Russia
does want to capture Ukraine intact
because they are that they're they're
essentially Brothers the Big Brother
little brother right like a lot of um
ukrainians are actually ethnically
Russian so they're trying to take
Ukraine over
um you know intact because here's the
thing people say oh Russia if they
really wanted to they have a lot of the
same weapons we have they could have
leveled Ukraine in a day if they really
want to take them over like we kind of
deal with Iraq airstrike airstrike
airstrike then bring in the ground
troops but they didn't do that they're
coming in they're systematically taking
in positions of power taking things from
a tactical advantage and that's what
they're doing and Ukraine is losing and
I don't know why we're still funding a
war that we're not winning and don't
have a chance of winning but zielinski
is trying to get as much money as he can
he's a scammer as well but criminal and
um it is what it is we're but the United
States looks at it like Hey we're able
to test our weapons we're not putting
our soldiers in line really we're able
to test our technology Etc up against
the Russians who if God forbid we get
into a war we could see it where we
stand so all parties here are winning
except for the Ukraine and then we're
talking about this from the American
perspective how much time we want to put
into this but how much time does
Vladimir Putin and Russia want to spend
on this what's the famous quote from
Afghanistan 30 seconds you might have
all the you might have all the watches
we have all the time yes so you know the
the the at the end of the day it's where
is this does Putin want to fight a
10-year War a 20-year War A Hundred Year
War uh it's happened in history people
can talk crap about Trump but this war
wouldn't happen if Trump was in office I
agree guys we can talk about this for
another hour on this topic Myron fire I
love how versatile you are on topics
what different happens when you talk
about it's phenomenal having you on I
really enjoyed listening I like these
talks yeah so except next time be on
time
so here's a couple things to keep in
mind here guys with this Friday from six
to ten uh the podcast these guys are
doing if there's one thing they know how
to do uh they know how to bring the
payments uh side out the entertainment
side fresh fit Adam it's going to be
entertaining as hell this Friday 6 to 10
p.m at 59.90 live on Federal in Fort
Lauderdale do not miss this one I think
the uh VIP is done I think the only
thing that's left is a few minutes and
some generals yeah and this is at what
generals 49 and then it's 149 for
Premiere I don't know what the price
point yes you guys haven't registered
get registered I'm only going to be in
the Cigar Lounge afterwards I'm gonna
come pop by in the last 15 minutes and
spend some time with the guys at the
Cigar Lounge but you're going to get a
chance to hear from him you're going to
get a chance to see this guy Ai and
you're going to get a chance to meet
maybe the most important person that's
going to be their lover boy
for me I'm a big fan I'm excited about
him being there so again go on the
website 59.90 live get registered Vinnie
you're going to be there as well I'm
gonna tell people don't don't do the
Middle Eastern minority thing where we
wait last minute those are going to go
fast as hell unfortunately the people
that complain the most about not getting
tickets are Middle Easterns because
we're minorities we wait because we
think we're cool well listen
Hispanics have a little bit of that as
well
don't judge us Middle East
I'll get Byron credit for knowing his
people he you know tickets were they
were starting to sell and he goes give
it to the left again go get ready so
we'll see there take everybody bye-bye
peace